so here we are you know i think
first of all we came off this is coming
off of
our biggest baddest
uh dramatic yeah
that was pretty bad uh how do you how
would you call it i don't want to say
i said meltdown or were you stormed off
but that seems to
that seems i think it was a meltdown was
it a meltdown i think i
kind of spiraled a little bit with all
the videos i made about you guys after
it was probably my most embarrassing
thing on
camera so it's really yeah of all the
things
yeah i think if you and ila didn't call
me yesterday i may not have come back so
i was
so embarrassed but because she was okay
with it i'm like alright let me try
i love doing this show it just it really
sucked it got to that but that was
pretty bad
it's i don't know so just to recap
by the way with us today mm-hmm and this
is pure chance people
people think we're faking this yeah
because with us today the last time we
had a big fight we had dr drew on to
mediate and he's back
with his colleague dr young now
first of all before we kind of dr young
what is your
background what what what is it that you
do here with dr drew
well ethan i'm a professor at university
of southern california in the marshall
school of business
and drew and i wrote a book
that came out 2010
on narcissism among celebrities oh no
[Laughter]
get this guy out of here
so uh drew and i've been friends and uh
kind of research partners for a long
time
and he told me about the show and
i thought it'd be fun to come on and
talk about the results of some surveys
yes okay so we took the person we took
personality tests
me and trisha both took the personality
test a month ago it was yeah
they needed time to crunch the numbers
well i'm just saying because we were
like in a good
space together we're like okay
everything's good and fun so not that it
would have changed the answers or
outcome but no but like the timing is so
because we were meant to already do this
today we had a huge fight on the last
episode
i'll be honest with you i didn't think
in my mind i was thinking well i'm gonna
have to wait and see until next year
yeah yeah you wanted a break and i kind
of pushed i don't know that's right
where i
really wanted to do more episodes and
then the doctor drew one specifically
because we had this plan and i was like
really wanting to do it again because i
loved the last episode so
yeah so you're like how about and then
you were like i'm gonna just say by
myself that we're taking a break i'm
like well can i at least come on with
you
and i said that's fair yeah but the
thing is we had dr drew and dr
young all scheduled and we scheduled you
guys can you guys confirm to me as phds
and doctors
let me get into this so so thank you for
having us back by the way
thank you for coming back i was
obviously
inundated with uh social media
notifications of what had gone down with
you guys
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to postpone this thing we had
scheduled and daniel
will confirm i pushed him to postpone it
if trisha wasn't gonna be here because
our original idea was
we're gonna measure this stuff and look
at what's going on with you guys
mostly because trisha you were so
gracious and so forthcoming last time
with all the information about
with the stuff you've been struggling
with i feel like we really made sense of
you know i sort of were able to look at
what was going on with you
i thought it helped he doesn't
understand who you are what you struggle
with
and obviously none of that work because
you guys have a huge blob
that people have to find out what that
was all about
but i but i feel like with each of these
blow ups you guys get
i wouldn't say closer together but it
helps you guys manage your relationship
better and the fact that you're back
today me
says it all trisha so thank you for
coming back yeah so happy new year
well it was interesting because after
our first meeting
my funky fight ready i'm gay after the
first meeting we had
i do feel like it deepened our
connection and we went for a long
stretch of time
very amicably very
just like good easy sailing be careful i
i don't want to ruin the show
well no it was good yes
well it was a healthy dose it was a
healthy back and forth banter
right until it became a little one-sided
in my opinion but that's jumping ahead
of myself i thought it was a little
one-sided the poking
that i wasn't allowed to poke back but
maybe i was wrong okay well
well do what how do you want to do this
because there's basically two ways we
can do this do you want to get into the
personality
test or do you want to know about the
meltdown i think i think everyone wants
to hear about the meltdown
because people are they're really people
were hand hanging on tinder hooks and
they're going to want to see it
okay so well what happened was and maybe
and i want to know how you got trisha
back here
too so what happened was i think we were
having a nice
normal episode everything was going
great
and then trisha mentioned something
about my
now this is very complicated trisha is
dating
my wife's brother okay
we knew that last time and so and so
she brought up something about my wife
and i said okay hold on you can't you
have to cut this because ila doesn't
want you
talking about that's a very big part
that you're wrong on this and very very
important that
he brought up ela he said last ila
watched the episode and said that there
was powdered sugar on your lips last
time
i'm like yeah that was the first thing
show them the tape rewind it that's okay
okay
well whatever he brought it up for ela
first
it's fine okay and so then i said oh we
should have her on everyone thinks we
hate each other
we don't it'd be funny to have her on he
goes nope
don't talk about ela and i was like it
wasn't said to me off camera to not talk
about it that she was off limits they
have a this is i'm on their channel like
we've always
so it just kind of caught me off guard
and that's when the pushing started
because then he
you know he started being like nope
can't talk about her she can't i'm like
why not like you guys talk about me on
your guys's podcast i'm on the channel
like
we've always talked about her like this
is kind of out of nowhere that i
obviously can't talk about your wife
who's a public figure so that's what
started the whole thing that spiraled it
obviously spiraled out of control on my
part but
it didn't spiral from that point first
just to know i could not break it
i think first of all i'm willing to
admit
my mistake i should have definitely
talked to you about this
before we started recording i should
have said hey
can i stop you right there that does not
feel like you mean it
oh it doesn't i do mean it i think
really clear that you mean it because it
because
this will come back around to virtue if
she isn't convinced
that you mean
no i i genuinely regret not talking
that was not fair for me to spring that
on you the way i did
okay but okay so so i so i was wrong
on that and i did text you and say that
right afterwards
this is what we did last time you guys
this is exactly what hold on you got to
see
you got to see what happened dr drew
well this is just like uh
we're on the titanic and you're like oh
there's an iceberg we didn't even hit it
yet
you know we just spotted it so there's
there's a lot of
tension between moses my brother-in-law
and ela my wife neither of them are here
right now just
which is good we did this by design and
we can talk about everybody
yes yes yours your wife's brother
yes yes my boyfriend yeah yeah
so here's where the problem comes in
trisha comes on the show
and she frequently repeats stuff that
moses tells her
so let me just finish my point then you
can respond
so for example trisha will say and you
did say in that episode
moses doesn't even like you guys anyway
or
she'll say she says she's joking when
she says stuff like this but
she goes well you're she says of ela's
mom
moses mom he he's not very close with
her and she wouldn't be invited to our
wedding
or you guys wouldn't be invited to our
wedding or you guys aren't close with
moses she always says stuff like that
that i feel like is
driving a wedge between
moses and his family okay so
and by the way and then there's more
there's more because
i don't think more i don't want there is
more this is important break it down
for this part there's one more piece
that i think is important
when i ask moses when ela asks moses
about it
moses says i didn't say that yeah
that's that's actually not important so
so but
somebody who okay relax
relax relax richard do you know what do
you know what splitting behaviors are
splitting we talked a little bit about
it last time
it's it's where you it's it's it has
many different sort of features one of
it is presenting differently to
different people
or presenting different aspects of the
truth to different people
or splitting one person's point of view
with another like if ethan says
i like green you go well moses says you
don't like rainbow and moses likes blue
that's splitting people does that does
that feel familiar to you
okay and so and you have talked about
your personality issues and one of those
issues
is is you'll have a tendency to split
you just will yeah
and ethan your job is to not respond to
splitting
yeah but she's but she's driving oh but
i can't
if she's know my wife
i gotta get on your case for this one
you are allowing the wedge to be put in
the place
she is doing what she does she is doing
her splitting thing
and your job is to go uh-huh
i'm not the one being split my wife is
being driven
apart from her brother and his own
family and mom
no one told me this prior to last week i
thought it was a jabs like he jabs me
i guess it's splitting and yes i know i
was jabbing him but it was
no one told me ela didn't tell me she
had a problem with it ethan didn't tell
me someone had a problem with it moses
no one told me that this was an actual
severe problem that's so severe i was
always talking to moses like you have to
should not
stop doing it how would i how would i oh
you never told me i did it on the show
multiple times and you cut out a joke
about his mom one time
and never even explained to you why you
put it out you could have been like hey
we're going to cut that but
when you would do it i would say you
have there was times when you would say
it i say you have to stop doing camera
which is why
all this is entertainment just like i
say stop it that's uncomfortable like on
camera okay if you tell me off camera
hey this is a real serious issue just
stop you never once said that
you've always had it on camera and i
always thought we were justing back and
forth you come from me i come for you
and i was like oh it's part of the show
the problem is that ila distrusts her
brother
because he's telling me things you're
kind of splitting
now you're sort of doing splitting
behavior so i'm not splitting
i'm not splitting should that be
presented on
on this show that issue i think it's out
there
okay so you're why but i think this is
an important issue
but they're not here right now listen
listen what do you think
reality is you can't tell where reality
is when this stuff gets going
so you shouldn't take offense when you
don't know
what's what you you you just can't take
offense and stuff when people are just
talking
later when you if you're able to
substantiate these things and find out
that you know moses is not trustworthy
or does feel the way that trish is
telling you
well then it's something to talk about
but in the meantime it's just
whatever don't don't react so you're
saying
so let's say um moses said so trisha
comes on she says moses says she doesn't
even like you guys
and then ila says hey why do you keep
saying this [ __ ] to trisha
she never said that ila never told me
that she never said why do you keep
saying this [ __ ] i've never talked to
moses to moses but not to me how am i
supposed to moses does not tell me
everything i did not know this
okay okay yeah i we we all agree eli
should have talked to you sooner and
when she did
you got i feel like you guys it was
totally fine
as soon as she talked to me i was
totally i was like i am so sorry too i
didn't know it was crossing a line
because
it was on the show and you're always
like stop it stop it but like i always
tell you to stop things and that's like
our thing
it's like you keep poking on stuff with
me so
well there's there's different different
levels of poking but like
but no one told me that they were truly
uncomfortable with it that it was like
upsetting their lives
i thought it was a job because very
little things bother you so that was the
thing that bothered you so i kept going
with it i was like obviously this
bothers him
the way you push on me that stuff that
bothers me
we're going to present to you guys very
very soon the the data
right about personality functioning and
what's going on
and i want you to understand when we do
that
these should not be used to pass
judgment on somebody just the way we
talked last time trish remember we
talked about just what is right it's
just these are features that you have
and you've got electron
and stuff and so of course you can have
these features but you have to be able
to sort of
manage that ethan you have to kind of
you kind of have to understand where
it's coming from and what it is
and you know sort of the problem i i
just i i never
i always i feel like whatever you throw
at me i can always deal with
the problem that happening that's
causing the friction is between
ela and her family as a result of things
that trish is saying
if it were up to me i would be here
every week and i feel like the things
that you say don't really get under my
skin
even in fact there's things like the
last week when you got really upset you
started attacking my parenting and stuff
it didn't it did i would i'm i can deal
with this i wasn't attacking and failing
i said do you want my opinion on this i
asked if you i did throw a jab i said
something like i want to have a nanny
then you said
tell me then how i should do i said do
you want my opinion you said when
there's two working adults i said do you
want my opinion and you said yes
i did throw the first jab at it but you
continued it and pushed it so tell me
about my parenting i'm like you really
want to know and you're like yeah i was
like all right this is what i would do
when i had a single mother that was
working my grandma watched me not a
nanny i had a babysitter that abused me
when i was five that was funny we don't
need to get into it
but you just said it no because it's
objective because it's objectively true
and there's i feel like there's no point
in debating not if i ask you do you
really want this because you were
pushing for me to give you
responses we don't have the clip so they
couldn't possibly know the context so
there's no point
but we have a clip it's very easy to
show them it's online
she was at the peak of her anger and she
wasn't the peak of my anger the peak of
my anger is
at the end okay well she was she was
rising up to it i realized what he was
doing he was pushing for a reaction i'm
like okay do you really want my opinion
on this situation no i wasn't pushing
for a reaction i was trying to make you
own what you said
no you kept asking me oh so now my mom's
a bad grandma that sounds that sounds a
little bit aggressive what does that
mean
because she says so we were so we came
to like
a point where she's like let's just move
on and i said great let's move on
and there's like a moment of silence and
then she says i'll tell you one thing
if i was lucky enough to have a kid i
wouldn't have a nanny
and that was a jab and i admit that but
he pushed
oh so what should we do if ela's working
at give me your advice to the parents i
said what do you mean by that and i said
do you really want me to answer that and
he said yes then he goes oh so now my
mom's a bad mom for not watching theater
so he kept pushing
and i'm fine with it if you wanted a
reaction but what like
that's what you're pushing for to me
responding and giving you a reaction i
was trying to
i was trying to figure out what you
meant so i'm not allowed to respond me
responding
so do you still think that i so do you
think that having a nanny's
tell me what do you think about the
truth about okay but you're asking me
right now
because you're not being honest okay
what if i do you want me to reply i will
be honest but i don't want you to be
like you're attacking my parenting do
you want my honor
no because you said well case you say
okay well your mom should be here then
i i do think i would i would have my mom
watch over annie i don't trust strangers
with my
my personal experience i don't think
your nanny's the worst i'm just saying
my personal experience
this is not the this is not the exact
conversation that happened i don't think
it's productive to go over it now well
you just asked me did you not just ask
me
to give you my opinion on this and
that's what i'm saying do you really
want me to tell you
i will i have no problem we already
talked about this okay but you just
asked me to give you an opinion again
about it
i heard your opinion i heard it i don't
i don't care to share it again i'm just
saying like if he wants to because
you're like
like it's it's very obvious that she was
in that moment digging as deep as
possible i was not digging
he was pushing me
you know also trisha that one of your
things is unregulated
us aggression hostility once it gets
going it goes right
yeah yeah and then ethan somehow can't
handle that
when that happens i can handle it well
no you escalated as opposed to just
containing it and so you got to watch
the clip you got to watch the clip to
see what really happened
yeah yeah but but i i want to go back to
something that that
i found curious why were you so
embarrassed tricia that that sort of
surprised me
or what you did on social media when
you're when you were in that state of
unregulated
aggression yeah i think cause like i
don't think that's ever been out there
like that i obviously like
that very end of it after all of that
when i realized like
he's pushing me and pushing me for a
reaction which i'm happy to give i'm
happy to
be that person because like i know it
can be entertaining or whatever and i'm
fine to be that way
it just was more embarrassing that i let
it go so far where i called like his
wife
really bad names i called her the c
where the b where i just was cursing out
a storm like i honestly don't even
remember
that part i remember the any part
remember all that that part i don't
remember all of a sudden my boyfriend
comes with the pizza
it seems like it's a big joke and people
are like laughing and that's this is my
perception it may not have been that way
and then all of a sudden i was thinking
like oh my god this is it so my
final thing was to to just end it i
thought you know every time i curse
someone out or go too far with someone's
wife or something like my ex-boyfriend i
cursed out his wife and then he broke up
with me that was the final straw i
thought this would be the final
ex-wife and so i thought like okay i'll
just end it like i'm gonna just go this
way and make sure we never talk again
and that's it and that's fine and people
get what they want
you ethan are you an eel are you and
everybody me and ethan like i really
i when i went to the car hysterical and
like hyperventilating because
so you you've described to me before
when you get in these days you sort of
black out were you in one of these sort
of blackout
i think towards towards the end because
i don't remember it was embarrassing
to watch it i saw it on tik tok and like
i don't remember saying all that and i
but i did feel immediately embarrassed
when i heard that because i was like wow
i literally went everyone in the
comments said that too like you went too
far she's attacking your wife and i
agree i'm in their house and their kid
was upstairs
and their child was upstairs and i was
like yelling and cursing all the way up
the stairs and it just was really
embarrassing like that part wasn't i
mean i was aware of it
but i just it was like i just couldn't
do anything i just kept cursing all the
way up the stairs it was
i don't know can i say something well
this is quickly i want to commend
both of you for being together being in
the studio let's really start from there
you know
you're trying to get your relationship
back together and it took a lot
for you guys to be sitting here as you
are today let's just acknowledge that
okay
and and so there's still a lot of
everyone's still kind of a hair trigger
you may need to clean up your side of
the street with some of that stuff right
you're aware
that make amends whatever to really make
things okay
but part of it is being willing to sit
here and take that embarrassment of
humiliation or whatever it is
yeah so here we are that's great ethan
you just wanted to say something
so i want to say that i don't know what
it is exactly you feel when you get to
that height heightened
state of emotion but in my mind i'm
never thinking like
oh she's out of my life forever she's
done i'm feeling like
well we can like i said to you let's
talk later
it's never like oh you're out of my life
forever you know what i mean
like she said something like i'm going
i'm quitting yadda yadda she called
yeah she said all all these bad words
and in my mind it wasn't like
bye forever i said why don't you leave
and we'll talk later
in my mind that means bye forever
because everyone says that and then it's
by forever like
with every situation that i've been in
in life like david and jason and all
that like it was by forever i did one
mess up where i went and said like went
on a rampage and then
they said bye forever they just cut me
out after being a year and a half
together every day with both of them and
it was just like bye forever and that's
how it always is so
that might be the right time to get into
the study the test
yeah because some of the things you
scored high on
is associated with a lot of difficulty
with shame and abandonment and you'll
you'll blow things up as opposed to
having somebody leave you
you know what i mean right and so so
this all sort of was born out in some of
the data we collected and i think we got
to get into that and before we do i want
to point out
these guys are not our patients they're
not human subjects they've asked us to
do these testing to sort of
you know just part of is just to sort of
objectify some of the stuff you guys
talked about and it's kind of
interesting
uh you guys also and the original
conceit was we would get you two
and measure your your inductor young
will explain the scale we're using
uh the scales we actually used a couple
of scales and then somebody thought well
why don't you test everybody on the air
step which we did
and there's stuff in there we could talk
about but our focus is
so uh regarding that because we tested
everybody
so we are going to be going over we
thought it would just it should just be
me and trisha today
we're tomorrow on the podcast we're
going to go over everybody else's
results
am i supposed to be abducted you don't
have to be there no no no dan you
you worked it out with with well before
you hopped on dr drew and
i'll cut this out we can just before you
hop down i was talking to dr
young and uh and he wasn't positive if
he could but i kind of explained the
situation and he also
i might be able to go up but i have a
colonoscopy tomorrow so we'll see what
conditions
by the way if you think this is like a
colonoscopy i actually have
dr drew if you i was just if you guys
could just like
send the data or the the
send us the score sheet like right you
know he offered to do that
uh as well but then he said i might be
able to come tomorrow
and so um we can settle that i wouldn't
i wouldn't
i wouldn't have dreamed of assuming uh
your guys's time tomorrow and i'm very
appreciative of you guys being here
today
both want to help you guys out we both
might be able to do it but as i said
i unlike
i'd love to ask you about that tomorrow
is it your first is it your first time
oh no i have something called lynch
syndrome so i have to have them every
year
oh so you're a veteran annual event i
get them
out of the way it never it gets easier
kind of but not really it never really
gets easier
well let's see i'm 35 so i guess in 10
years i will
experience my first uh right they say
40.
you might do your just a quick aside
here i make all my patients get these
genetic tests
uh you can get them at some i'm not
involved with this organization but it's
called
color.com just like colorgraincolor.com
and uh i see the menorah up there and
i'm guessing ashkenazi is in your
heritage
and there's a lot of dna repair
abnormalities in that heritage in iowa
and if you have lynch syndrome you might
uh need colonoscopies over here
well dr drew i'll tell you one thing
about myself
i did a dna test and i'm 99.3 percent
ashkenazic
recommend you to go to color.com and do
this
good idea rocket jeans right well there
are
genes like that for other cancers and
ashkenazis carry a lot of them so you
might
check it out that's a good idea thank
you i'll do that
appreciate anything for you no i think
i'm good
i mean i don't know i'm not good but
just other
different yeah different okay where were
we um
we're trying to we were gonna i was just
i was just i'll reset up that like
so we all took the personality test
that'd all be on the i don't mind
all that going on the podcast yeah we
can put we can we can put it all up too
i don't know
fair enough yeah okay the whole cut yeah
so where were we we're gonna we're gonna
try to set you guys we present your dad
let's present the data personality tests
so what kind of personality test did we
take maybe you guys can start by
explaining that
it's up to you you're
yeah off guys we uh we gave you two
personality tests one is called
the npi or the narcissistic personality
inventory
and that was 40 questions
40 pairs of questions where you had to
choose
a or b whether you agreed with
point a or point b more and then
i was able to sum up your scores
on that test and come up with an overall
score but the npi
the 40 questions are also broken down
into seven
subcategories and i'll go over those
with you in just a minute
because it's very diagnostic the second
test that we gave you is called the dark
triad
and this is a test that's been around
for almost 20 years
and what that test does it also assesses
narcissism but it includes a measure of
machiavellianism oh [ __ ] and psychopathy
well how wait machiavelli's him that
seems like what would be a more
that's is that like sadism i mean what
is that that's like uh
like sociopathy what is that oh no no so
um the term machiavellianism
comes from a 16th century
italian politician and diplomat
called nikolai machiavelli and so he
wrote a very famous book in in the 16th
century called the prince
and essentially what he did was he
advised
this prince um on how to
to use guile and cunning to get what he
wanted
so he's the term machiavellianism is
always associated with that book
i i always feel i have to defend
machiavelli because he also wrote the
republic
and he felt that the republic was the
best form of government
but he wrote the prince in which he i
advocated for ruthlessness
if you have a prince while you while you
figure out how to set up a republic so
in like
so in a political sense someone who's
machiavellian is someone who is kind of
manipulative or cunning or how would you
say
yeah that's exactly right cunning
engages in
self-interest often lacks uh
emotion can be duplicitous uh
you know these aren't good good traits
can you be
narcissistic but also like
an empath like actually care about
people can you be into yourself and
also care about other people or no can i
answer that
because it's an interesting it's
something that uh some of the old
self psychology theorists they called it
reverse narcissism
which is that you are so concerned with
other people you're overly concerned
with other people because they trigger
feelings in you it's still trying
you it's you know some people experience
themselves first and then other people
second
some people experience other people as a
way of experiencing themselves and some
people go back and forth
but if you're so focused on the other
that
your boundaries aren't able to be
maintained where somebody's having a
feeling you're sort of overtaken by it
your conscious sense of it can be oh i'm
so attuned to that person i you know i
have a special understanding of them
really you don't have a special
understanding it's just your pain that's
sort of blending with their pain and
it's hard to tell the difference
we also call that codependency right
so so i have that i have that in spades
i do and i
had to get a lot of therapy to sort of
sort out what was
other personally experiencing versus
mind it's very challenging stuff
it's sort of you know and i suspect
trisha you you get you get too revoked
by other people yeah i have a book i
read called codependent no more because
that was
literally me to a t last year i just
couldn't i couldn't survive without
what called codependent no more but you
said you had that to what oh
last year yeah to every relationship
like i cannot function like if like i
don't
if i'm not if i don't have someone in my
life to like manage me and like to also
just
have someone i just i can't i can't
function i can't function without a
boyfriend
and so you have lots of layers that you
just mentioned another one is you you
use people you use your
intimate partner to help you stay
together too to be glued together right
yeah and that's again so that's all it's
all
you know please don't think of these
terms
you know when you use a term like
machiavelli people automatically go
sort of south on the judgmentalism
these are just i try not to be
judgmental in how you think about these
things right we all have narcissism
to varying degrees not me no i'm kidding
we'll find out
[Laughter]
i'm scared i'm scared too i was scared
answering these
it was like do you like to look at
yourself in the mirror you know what
yeah
the thing is like um the questions
felt a little tricky right yeah cause
like i feel like you phrased them
differently in like three different ways
to try to trick me into
like catching myself so but but
um i should say this that drew and i
didn't invent
the npi this was invented probably close
to 50 years ago oh i thought you guys
came up with these questions i was like
wow they're smart oh no
no it's it's been tested with tens of
thousands of people
oh okay um and so the questions aren't
really designed to trick you
but they're designed to kind of make you
think and to force you into making a
choice between
right these two pairs right so going
back to
trisha's question narcissism really is
not something that is what we call a
monolithic construct
in other words it's not just one thing
there are actually
in this scale seven different aspects of
narcissism let me just read those off to
you
uh authority superiority
self-sufficiency exploitativeness
vanity exhibitionism and entitlement
so you can break the 40 questions down
into scores on each of those seven
categories
interesting is is it usual for
narcissists to like
hit all of those categories or is that
what makes a narcissist or do we all
have different levels of those each
category
you all have different level and you
know drew and i often talk about the
so-called good aspects of narcissism
which consists of authority
superiority and self-sufficiency and
perhaps the not so good aspects which
consist of exploitativeness
vanity exhibitionism and entitlement
even when you think about those
so-called
less i don't know adaptive sorts of uh
uh scales
i mean vanity and uh
uh sort of what was the last category
not exploitativeness before after that
uh exhibitionism exhibitionism and
vanity exhibitionism
i mean it didn't hurt anybody you know
what i mean it's like those to me those
are sort of neutral
what do you mean by exhibitionism like
naked like you like
looking at yourself are you like like
what does that mean because i mean i
know
it means generally to be seen and to
look at people right so what does it
mean clinically
the same thing yes oh okay i understand
it
and then another question i have about
the test if you'll indulge me
is that on on one of the tests there was
like a sliding scale of like
agree strongly disagree and there was
like what i forget how many bubbles but
like
what is it you're looking for because i
felt like on a lot of them i didn't have
a strong opinion one way or the other
you know so that was uh those that scale
was
associated with the dark triad survey
so that was different from the
narcissistic personality inventory oh
it's not it has nothing that one had
nothing to do with the narcissism
well in the dark triad there are these
three components and narcissism is also
part of the dark triad but why is it
called the dark triad that's so spooky
well it's called the dark triad in part
has these three things
psychopathy machiavellianism and
narcissism
are meant to be things that um
characterize people as as
social or sometimes that you know are
cunning
callous self-interested and things like
that so
uh people have put these things together
into this scale to try to describe
certain aspects of human behavior now
let me just sort of explain it to you
this way the way i think about it is if
if you are a fighter pilot uh
trying to make a landing on a uh
aircraft carrier
you want that person to be as
narcissistic as possible right you want
him or her to feel invincible grandiose
no anxiety i mean you want all that
stuff in that person
for your intimate partner the problem
person
like that may also have difficulty with
empathy
and envy and also in certain states
much like we were talking about with
trisha when she blacks out
your feelings don't matter in certain
states
and she can't appreciate their skin
remember that you have feelings
and that's part of the unregulated stuff
that happens when when you get upset
right
yeah doctor can we recall the dark triad
i feel like it's a little bit judgmental
it is it has been that way maybe maybe
we could just call it
the uh these people are [ __ ] up
triad or something like that i think the
reason the dark triad comes
because because it includes a scale of
psychopathy and psychopathy
writ large can be pretty dark okay
but mild psychopathy is is a you know
just a nuisance all right let's do this
so let's start with the uh
they're a winner on these tests or no
like is there right and wrong tell me
who's the narcissist
like is there is there like someone
that's coming out better than the other
person with these tests or it's just
like a
not a comparison wait what are you uh
are you asking is one of us more
narcissistic than the other yeah
yeah well actually it's a very good
question thank you
well i wasn't sure quite what you're
doing i love being at that i thought you
would be like i score
no to make negative one stop i didn't
know just
to put your scores in context the
national average
out of 40 is about a 15.
so um let me just kind of tell you what
each of your scores are
and then we break them down into
categories and we want to score high
closest to 40 or we want to score low
i think high is bad depends on your
perspective i guess
high is bad i think high is more
narcissistic right okay i got it yeah
okay yes
yes so the closer to 40 the more
narcissistic so
let's start with some easter eggs
i want to take a guess ethan as to what
you support
is this part of the test no no they're
just uh
out of 40 let me ask you this what who's
the what's the highest you've ever seen
have you ever seen a perfect 40
no but we have seen the 34. oh so 34 is
like
wow this guy and what do you do with the
34 you just put him away
that's a famous score guys yeah it's a
famous person who actually got that
score whoo
he's afraid to say it because it's been
an issue up until this day should i say
it wait
is it robin quivers yes wait
i knew it i can't believe robin quivers
that's iconic
she's the howard stern i know robin but
i just i remember seeing you guys do
that test and you saying that she has
the highest score
ever and i didn't know if that was stick
or not that's iconic
really don't happen the big mistake we
made and i've apologized for alvin a
million times
she's not accepted my apology well she's
a narcissist
which is that in which howard loves
ribbing her about to this day
um is that we because it happened on the
air
publicly we assumed there would be no
issues when we wrote our book we wrote a
book about we went and studied
groups of celebrities and so we just
wrote just in the book here was our
highest score here was our lowest score
she took great issue to that saying we
should have permission
oh really that's what really caused the
problem and i and i
she's right it didn't occur to us
because it happened publicly
but you're right she we should have we
should i i felt really bad about that
and so
ah i'm still trying to make amends
different i would be honored if i was in
your book you could write about me
anytime
so trish is i think trish is looking to
get the highest score
if she knew if she knew she would have
answered all the questions differently
okay generate another one okay okay okay
on the narcissistic cisco you say the
average is what
average is 15 the high the highest
possible score is 40.
so what do you got
maybe a 15. i say eight maybe average
eight for ethan okay well ethan actually
got a seven
oh oh that's nice i think
he's he's very self-deprecating and has
a low self-esteem and
so i overall life i knew you wouldn't be
low self-esteem
i think you have issues without you too
we have similar self-esteem
so okay let me ask you this that's
trisha insults me does a low narcissism
score doesn't mean that you don't
have confidence as a human being does it
i don't know but now remember now
in the moment we're going to get to the
specific categories in which those seven
numbers fall
okay good good go back so that means
that
so so i got a very good score i think
i'm a good human being now
it's not about this no no yes it is yes
it is to be a narcissist and be a good
human being no
yes not most of the time i'm just
kidding i'm just [ __ ] with you
i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm gonna be
really
[Laughter]
there's a scale somewhere i'm [ __ ] up
on but let me but let me say this
what does it mean i feel like i'm kind
of surprised and i'm kind of happy that
that i'm
my my narcissism scale is low and by the
way let me
also say that if your narcissism score
is too low
yeah associated with sort of
not initiating and not being creative
and not not coming your own defense and
things you need
to be your [ __ ] you're calling me a
[ __ ]
i'm wondering it makes me wonder you you
react so quickly and strongly
and it's just my observation to some of
the stuff trisha says i wonder if this
figure's into that in some way
she called me a [ __ ] when she stormed
out
your cockpit she said she said your wife
is a c word
and she said and you're a cuck so maybe
that maybe i have a
maybe i am a cuck is someone who likes
to watch his wife have sex with other
men
there you go thank you thank you
which by the way i am not i do not
that's not something i'm interested in
despite
he likes to flex his power over me
sometimes because he might feel powerful
powerless in other aspects who's a seven
on the narcissism scale
so you want to flex the power over me
because you don't have power a seven on
the narcissistic system scale wouldn't
do that
you see a weak and you see someone
that's hated on the internet and you go
you assert your power over me but that's
whatever seven what's yours 10 billion
next listen to this actually here we go
so
uh trish let's do the same with you okay
national average 15 highest possible is
40 where do you think you stand
i always like to say i'm right in the
middle at like 20 because i don't think
i should
lead the world but i do like to look at
myself naked so i would say i'm a nice
20.
let me guess before you say so robin
quivers comes in at 35 you said
34. see it's so it's interesting that
the top
uppermost scale doesn't isn't really
reached
40 yeah 40 that's like on
you'd have to be like so so you think
you're 20
average is 15 i think you're higher than
20.
i think you're probably at 25. wow
well no don't say well i mean it's not
no wow in 80s
don't sugarcoat it dr drew
all right so the big reveal is
that tricia scored the 30 out of 40.
holy [ __ ]
oh i missed it by five points whoa
you're waiting
i mean if i'm gonna be up there i might
as well be over robin like i don't want
to be can she take it again
i know could she take it again she wants
that 35.
[ __ ] so wait how so what so what
percentage of people
score that high 35 well
30 actually a 34 is what they call three
standard deviations above the average
which means that
you're you're higher than 99 percent of
the population wow
i'm in the top 1 well that's a 33
30 is probably around 97
98 no i thought it would have been like
80 or something so
but she's 35 though you said no i'm 30.
i wanted to be there all right i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry 30. so
so wow yeah let's break them down so you
can see what's going on so
let's go back to easton for a moment so
ethan the cup go ahead
i was feeling pretty happy and then drew
made me feel bad when he said that i'm
like [ __ ] basically calling me a beta
well look you know remember this the
seven categories here you
you have points in three of those
categories
authority you get a three out of eight
self-sufficiency of two out of six
an entitlement a two out of six
so remember the authority and
self-sufficiency factors
are considered the healthier types of
narcissism
right so you have five of your seven
points
are in those healthier categories thank
you dr yan
dr young is my man dr drew sucks
i'm just kidding thank you guys i'm just
trying to be entertaining here but i do
appreciate that and
i am not a [ __ ] interestingly though you
have two other six and entitlement
oh and nothing else in any other
categories
so so when you say oh so when you say
two out of six there were six
questions regarding entitlement i scored
on two of them
so can you wonder no wonder he likes
seeing his wife have sex with somebody
else
[Laughter]
wait can you do those again because i
didn't quite understand say read it
again from the top
okay so you've got three out of eight on
authority okay
two out of six on self-sufficiency okay
six on the entitlement
okay i have to say that these are low
scores across the board really
it's just interesting to us that the
categories that you fell into authority
and
self-sufficiency in particular are you
know again what we consider the
the more positive aspects of narcissism
i think
what we can really draw from this is
that as far as narcissism scores go
this is probably one of the best and
healthiest scores you guys
have ever seen i wouldn't go that far
not prepared to say that they said too
low is bad too yeah but they said i had
okay whatever thank you guys i love
doctor
baby if you if you fire me from the
podcast maybe me and dr drew can have
another podcast he has like eight of
them so i feel like i could join one
with him
if you let me go is that true dr germany
podcast you have
let's do a plug dude plug your podcast
speaking of machiavellianism she's
uncovered my evil plan
dr drew understands me see i just want
someone to understand me and this is why
it's like so nice you know how boring
that show will be it's just you at
therapy
no we we did a podcast together it was
very entertaining me adam doctor
how boring would it be dr drew go ahead
it would be because
i actually do very well with with peop
with people with
atricious profiles i i've actually sort
of treated like oh so you are pitch you
say you are as receptive
yes because it would just be me sort of
holding it holding things together and
that neck that's what i need then i can
because i felt vulnerable
dr drew as a co uh you said you have an
issue with uh codependency so
that's where that comes in right so like
i was unable i would
be unable to put the show ahead of
trisha's needs
right i'd be like i don't eat that
though no you don't want to put the shot
do me a favor
do me a favor and go make a show with dr
drew
i just appreciate someone putting my
needs before a show can i i want to
before
i i do want to continue on yes but by
the by the end of this i do want to
complain to you dr drew and maybe you
can set her straight
about this issue that keeps coming up
about money she's always complaining
about money
hey that's what i'm not complaining
about because i don't want to hear about
it anymore i'm not complaining about it
we'll talk about it
i make a point okay so so let's continue
sorry for the side note
trisha let's break down your 30 points
remember the national average is 15.
just to remind you thank you you've got
a
six out of eight on authority five out
of six on self-sufficiency
what was it self-sufficiency was what
not what number
five out of six five out of six i'll
take it that's good yeah i'm very
self-sufficient yeah that one's good
yes and then uh three out of six
on entitlement yeah um
six out of seven on exhibitionism
that makes sense yeah for sure she she's
a she works in porn so
i'm top one top one percent on only fans
yeah
yeah okay then three out of three
on vanity whoa wait stop the stop
a perfect score on vanity which makes
sense because
trisha to this day still thinks that me
a happily married man
wants to [ __ ] her she's obsessed with
that yeah that is a condition i have
where i think literally
just remember next time you think that i
want to [ __ ] you you have a three or
three on i think i have sexual attention
with everyone it is a problem i
i'm i'm pretty sure not everybody wants
to have sex with me but i love things
love to see the questions can you read
the vanity questions that you marked
yesterday
is that possible um you'd have to give
me a moment i'd have to go back through
it because i would love to read what you
said yes to because they were really
extreme
i do think very highly of myself for
some reason i mean i hate my weight but
i
i think i'm very beautiful on a scale of
one to ten
be like 10 being most beautiful women in
the world what would you give yourself
it's so hard to say because i consider
myself a complete package so to look at
me i don't think i'm a 10 but the
complete package is most definitely a
10. yeah three out of three for sure
dude
you're talking to a zero out of three
across from you
did i really have a zero three on vanity
yes oh my god
oh my gosh see that's what i said i
could take at least one out of three you
know what i mean i told you you had like
low self-esteem i know you do i know you
have this like complex because you were
skinny at one point and you have a
complex well related to it i'm not
trying to
feel you you know what i mean i do feel
yeah
but why because of your weight i
sometimes do i feel like i might have
confidence but maybe just not physical
confidence like i don't think that i'm
like
like as a person i have confidence but i
also think i'm a disgusting fat
[ __ ] i know confidence to see your wife
or somebody else no big deal
[Laughter]
yes please let's hear the vanity
questions
here are the vanity questions remember
these are two questions you have to
choose a or b
and so one question says
i don't particularly like to show off my
body
and the second choice is i like to show
off my body so i said i don't like
showing off my body and you said i do
of course yeah that makes sense i always
want to show you like my squirting and
stuff i'm like here look but like
okay but that makes sense i i that
totally is that one's
okay so what's next and the next one is
my body is nothing special
or i like to look at my body so for me
obviously my body is nothing special and
you like to look at it i love my body i
had lipo i had a butt transfer you like
looking at your body i love i do think
my body is very attractive
really because i hate okay because i
don't like looking because i'm just i'm
out of shape it's bad
i have a lot of good jiggle like i have
a slow motion on my ass jiggling i have
a lot of nice
nice that you're confident about a
confident a lot of people like to look
at my body i make a million dollars a
month and have people look at my body
that's true so you have no reason not to
well the last question is um i like to
look at myself in the mirror
or i'm not particularly interested in
looking at myself in the mirror you said
no you're not interested
no i'm not particularly interested
really so but like see
shocking i can't stop staring at myself
in these monitors i look at myself the
entire episode
do you really even notice it but like
see i feel like my answers
it's like i'm not particularly
interested look at myself in the mirror
that seems to me like a like a pretty s
like healthy
attitude no i guess
well i don't think about these questions
as
yeah yeah yeah yeah come on you're
calling me a
call episode now you're playing it all
diplomatic
these are these are forced answers
that have predictive value you have to
think about it then okay
okay interesting let's continue i mean i
i i'm absolutely fascinated by all this
me too i i i never even thought of
vanity as being narcissist i guess that
is
never mind i don't know what i'm talking
about i would imagine it would be well
yeah okay interesting
i knew that three out of three i'll take
it
that's five of the the uh we were going
through precious categories yeah
the last one is exploitativeness
and trisha you got a two out of five on
that that's good what's exploitativeness
that's like taking advantage of of
taking advantage oh yeah i'm what would
that be
too yeah tell me the two that she
answered
jesus positiveness yeah i love you
that's the interesting
take advantage of you like to be on this
podcast
you manipulate a little bit and that
also you should show up on the
machiavelli scale a little bit to them
for sure i've been called a manipulative
person multiple times
right and i'm not sure you are aware of
it when you're doing it
yeah i bet you feel bad about it when
it's called into consciousness
but but it's some defensive strategy you
have yeah i don't ever know when i'm
doing it i
will still do this to say like i'm not
manipulative but people keep saying it
so i'm like maybe i am but i honestly
don't
intentionally try to be i try and be as
authentic as i can so people don't think
that about me but
well authenticity is is not
not manipulative i mean right
people think i manipulate the audience
by talking about borderline in general
because this is a recent diagnosis as of
last year and going into therapy and
everyone's like wow she's manipulating
the audience by saying she has
borderline personality disorder i'm like
well i don't know you guys call me crazy
and then i say i have a disorder and
then they're like oh she's manipulating
and i don't know what that is like
i don't know what where the confusion
lies i i don't think that's manipulative
but but i think what they're doing
people i see this all the time with drug
addicts too which is people don't
like them to have
i don't know how to say this to have an
out you know what i mean when you say
you've got a brain disorder then people
have to be
sympathetic to you right when they're
angry with you for some behavior they
don't like being sympathetic you know
what i'm saying
yeah yeah that's it because they call me
crazy for so many years never got
diagnosed until i was 31 and then
they're just like well now she's being
manipulative we should all just walk
around eggshells around trash i'm like
well well it's hard when people don't
know you in real life and they just see
you online and it's like this and this
and this and this you know what i mean
well that's where i'm trying to be
authentic so people can kind of see more
of me but it's hard
so so guys i found the two questions um
for trisha on exploitativeness
option one is i can read people like a
book
or people are sometimes hard to
understand
oh i feel like i can read people very
well like a book
that's the thing some of those questions
like because like for me i'm like i feel
like sometimes
i can get a read on people but but like
to make a statement like i can read you
like a book it's like no i can't read
people like a book
no but i think i can read people yeah
that is part of borderline
right because with borderline they like
have antennas up to people's emotional
states
uh both in because they've been
traumatized and they're they're always
ready to sort of react that
but some of the borderline process did
we talk about this last time did we talk
about projectile identification last
time
no i don't think so okay so what happens
and this is what you guys
were getting into in your last meltdown
which is that when
borderlines experience feelings that are
awful they kind of disavow them
and put them in the other person and
make you feel awful
they literally able to it sort of inject
feelings into you
it's a very it's a very it's b think
about what babies do when they want to
get fed
they make all kinds of noise that makes
you feel a certain way that makes you
come to go take care of them
borderline people with borderline
disorders use that same mechanism
and it's it's it can be crazy making in
the person nearby
because you don't know why you're
feeling all the things you're feeling
and borderlines are hyper acutely aware
of what's going on
in you like a book like a book and then
what was the other one
all right so the the second question is
i will never be satisfied
until i get all that i deserve or
i will take my satisfactions as they
come
wait what was the first the first one i
will never be satisfied
be satisfied until i get
that's so intense i don't remember
checking that but i guess the excess
between the two i guess yeah i should
get it all i deserve
my thought process when i when i read
that was like well i don't think people
necessarily
desi i don't think that i necessarily
just it's the way it's written is it's
so sharp it's like
yeah it'd be nice to be satisfied with
certain things but i don't necessarily
think that i deserve
like everything i want you know what i
mean i deserve everything i want i do
but i feel like everybody should think
that i think everyone should like think
they deserve everything in this life
to me that seems like a really that
seems like a really
dark way to go about the world of like i
deserve how can everybody possibly
deserve
everything they are all humans we're all
created from god like we all deserve
like his blessings on earth like i
believe that
and everyone should feel that way
okay antichrist i'd love to know what
god how god scores on a narcissism scale
he would probably be a perfect scorer
maybe
maybe that's an issue to look at all
right well this was great so we have
another test to go over
which i'm assuming trisha failed
spectacularly as well yeah more to say
about this test oh sorry
yeah just before we leave that i mean
the discussion that you you guys just
had about those questions
is an indication of how differently
people feel about
their life and their perceptions right
you guys see things the same question
differently which is what these types of
surveys it's really interesting yeah
because to be totally fair when i was
reading some of these questions
i could tell that it was like oh i was
like who would mark yes on this i mean
not to disre yeah but i was like i can't
even imagine
making such a strong statement as like i
deserve
everything in the world i think it's
more manifesting i don't want to say i
don't deserve everything so i'm like i'd
rather say i deserve everything
doesn't say you don't deserve it it said
you will not be happy until you get
everything you deserve
yeah better than the alternative option
is how i looked at it the alternative
option isn't that you don't get things
that you want it was just so extreme
that i was like no
of course i can't i can't mark yes to
that i thought differently but
i mean that's fascinating right doctors
literally you literally see it
differently you literally think about it
from a different perspective yeah that's
what happening here
all right so let's turn to the dark
triad and the
yeah why don't we just call it the yeah
that should be our podcast the dark
triad
oh we need a third person if we're gonna
be a triad
dr drew yeah exactly
well guys i can tell you that the dark
triad has really
kind of entered popular culture too
because you know every now and then i
watched this
tv show swat and last night
i think somewhere they were rerunning an
episode where
they were chasing this criminal and
amazingly they said this criminal has
these three characteristics
machiavellianism narcissism and
psychopathy
and they actually use the words so
this is something that we're going to
see a lot more of interesting things
let's get to it so with the dark triad
a high score in machiavellianism is a
3.86 out of 5.
well i'm sorry what is this pie 3.86
3.8 why the decimal
just because of the thousands of people
that they've tested oh i see i
misunderstood
so the average is a 3.8 sorry say that
again
3.86 because out of five is the average
okay people seem pretty
evil earlier if you asked about the
number of bubbles you know like they're
strongly just right i got it oh that's a
five-point scale sorry
okay got it narcissism a high score is
3.68
and above got it and then psychopathy
is a 3.4 and above and psychopathy is
sociopathy i'm assuming you know
people it defines again this is a
debatable point and people get very
theoretical about this
i make a distinction between sociopathy
and psychopathy
sociopaths are people that are
manipulative
and really don't care or don't really
appreciate that you have feelings you're
just there to serve their needs right
psychopath doesn't have feelings so i i
think they're
really kind of assessing in this scale
sort of people's ability to
appreciate emotions i think that's what
they're talking about are there any
good psychopaths um it's a good question
there's such a thing as pro-social
psychopaths
right and um there are i have friends
that work in this field
uh and you know i've i this is
i don't wanna get destroyed for this one
this is not my opinion this is an
opinion of a couple friends of mine
who work in the field of psychopathy
they feel that bill clinton was a
pro-social psychopath
he was he was interested in doing things
that were good and good legislation and
helping people
but he had no trouble exploiting this
young intern
and didn't think anything of it that's
a social psychopath i could see it but
is it
is [ __ ] an intern really like because
i feel like a lot of powerful
men do that they're just like yeah [ __ ]
the intern obviously
did you see the uh the clinton affair
the documentary no i haven't i should
watch it
yeah but it's much more profound really
so where can i watch that just to
not not to promote i just generally
curious i think it's on netflix
oh my how did i not how did that i never
did that not show up on my netflix page
i'm watching that tonight
i can't i can't i'll look it up here
right now but but it it was
i'll find it it's called the clinton
affair okay ah
at what he did today really question
just real quick
over years it really was something else
when i was younger
i like envied monica lewinsky like i
thought oh she's getting all this fame
for [ __ ] the present like i wanted to
be her so bad i thought she was like
lucky like what is that because
even like you know like i wanted to like
be with like michael jackson i want to
be with jerry lee lewis like all these
people who like
dated like minors and stuff and then the
intern i was like she's so famous she
had to [ __ ] the president like i want to
be at this level where
snl is parodying me like what is that
because i still like obviously i know
it's wrong and gross now but like i
still was like like i romanticized i
thought that was so cool i was like i
wish that was me like i still wish it
could be me with the president you know
interesting a couple things i mean
that's sort of machiavellianism right
anything to get to get the job done is
sort of machiavellianism
and then that one question you answered
where you know i'll do anything to get
all my needs mad or whatever that was
that's kind of that isn't it
you want the fame and you saw that they
achieved it easily
oh i was like that's all you want to be
the president's dick i wanted yeah that
was a
and she was like sexual the president
wanted her and i was like oh i want that
like the president wants to [ __ ] you
that's so cool like i thought that was
like an
honor huh i still would love to have sex
with bill clinton i know it's funny i
i i had the same thoughts what about
mama
i'm just kidding i think it's on netflix
i think
i'm gonna watch the [ __ ] out of that man
actually it's a great documentary
it was wait well i'm like the scales
fell from my eye
it was that's i i'm super interested
yeah i wonder what it means about
hillary too because she stay with him
she knows what the kind of guy he is
i mean i mean it's very uh it is very uh
you know house of cards right you should
be aware of this
um tricia people with borderline
disorders tend to be very attractive to
sociopaths
oh i know that path to them so it's just
whenever why is that well i nobody
really knows that i know of but but
it whenever we would get a sociopath and
a borderline on a drug unit together
we'd have to go to great lengths to keep
them apart and prevent them from having
sex huh
i wonder if it's because the sociopath
knows how to manipulate them and has no
qualms doing it
maybe maybe and the borderline sort of
believes it you know what i mean and
wants to go with it and they're very
entertaining and makes them feel good
i've never broken up with a boyfriend
they've always dumped me i've never
broken up with someone
true story yeah i just don't want to
lose anybody i'm just like you know what
just stay even if they cheat
give me sds i'm like whatever stds yeah
i mean
with people on that yeah what's
one thing about him is like that's not
what happened i
it's not even what we're talking about i
just noticed do i say oh you have baby
hands put it next to your face your huge
head with your baby hands no i don't say
that because that's rude
it's just makeup i don't have baby hands
put it next to your face it's on amazon
prime
all right amazon prime let's move on
okay some people have accused trisha of
being a blackfish you know what that is
that's not it's someone who tries to
look black who's white
i am 18 moroccan we have two doctors
here
what do you make about black fishing
i've never heard of it
no comment yeah okay let's continue
stupid poor doctor
poor doctor young is way over his head
and i at least knew what i was getting
into yeah it willingly came back
all right so looking at the dark triad
uh let's just go through ethan's scores
on machiavellianism you got a 2.3
and remember a high score is 3.86 so
you're
below that level quite significantly so
a 3.8 is i thought you said that was the
average or that's the highest
that's considered high and what's
average
uh they don't really report the average
um
but anything above 3.86 is considered a
high number
and you're a 2.33 below average yet
again
so
okay nice i mean that's good i i feel
happy about that
on narcissism you're 2.44
and remember the high score was 3.68
so you're you're below on narcissism i
feel great about that too
and then now is that consistent with my
previous narcissism score
because it seems higher no it's
consistent
i think it's consistent it's the scales
are a little bit different
a little bit higher in narcissism on
this scale than you are on the other one
but not significantly so i see
and then on psychopathy yeah 1.77
so what does that mean about me as a
person doctors if you would analyze me
based on that
you have to remember this again do what
you want to call me a cuck again dr drew
it's not what i brought you here bring
it up again just tell me i'm a great
person
perfect okay i'm just kidding
i think look we all know trish is the
[ __ ] show here so
well first of all thank you i take i
like being the titles in the headlines
like i like the attention for sure
why do you complain about it maybe this
test is saying like maybe
why do you complain a little more why do
you complain to me
i love doing the show i'm the one that
no i'm not quitting you
text me you go stop putting me in the
headline
stop putting me in the highlights after
because because he wanted to continue
the show without me today
to get the revenue on this without me i
said let me be honest it's not
at all about revenue it's about it is
you saying trish i wasn't to do it
without you yes you said you were
anyways you said you were going to do
the show without me by no we talked
no i wasn't going to do the show without
you i was just going to explain what
happened by using me in the title he
says ethan talks to trish i said don't
use my name in the title if you don't
need it
because that's like i'm not getting the
monetary value off our drama okay
whatever okay well anyways that's what
you're the narcissist you're the dark
triad over here
i'm i'm just kidding the doctor's like
don't do that
i'm just kidding thank you like honestly
we can only do the show with them i feel
safe with them here
they actually know what they're talking
about you just honestly like i'm the one
look you feel safe with them i don't
know what's their score on the dark
triad
well i'm too i'm too scared of you for
being too low on the dark triad like why
aren't you a little
so okay like a little life in you a
little life i mean does it mean that i'm
lifeless that i'm
low on the dark triad no but i worry
about you coming to your own defense
and being able to really i i
would wonder about good boundaries which
is again why i think
trisha gets gets you going gets gets dan
i mean dan you know me you know me
fairly well at this point what do you
think about the
about the narcissism and the dark triad
low scores
uh i i think that it tracks i would say
the only one that
surprises me a little bit is um is
that what was it was was it the
machiavellian that
that he was like a one point something
on that was a psychopathy
oh psychopathy okay because you can be
pretty cunning
when it comes to you you're a wonder
you're shrewd businessman and you you
make
smart moves and he's not really when i
address the highlights he goes
i have no control over the highlights
i'm like it's your channel and your
employees you have all the control over
the highlights what are you talking
about
but i guess machiavellian really means
well done those are two different things
right it means it's more manipulative
and and because to me
when i when i do something it's not like
i'm not i feel like i'm not being
deceptive like making making
good decisions about business or
relationships i feel that honesty is a
is is a is a large part of of how i
maneuver myself
in business and in relationships you
know
but but like when when you say
psychopathy
that again just to clarify that's marked
by
a lack of emotion is that what that
means or what if you're way up on that
scale it's a lack of emotion
okay okay so you have emotions you're
like a human which is good i'm human
i'm very human i'm extremely human
you know but ethan i think overall if
you have a low score in the dark triad
basically we're saying that you know you
tend to not be a manipulative person
you're not particularly callous
you're not particularly selfish right um
you know those are the kind of things
that
a low score would indicate right i think
it's good to have a low score on this
one
so let's let's talk about i agree i feel
i feel happy about that yeah
thank you thank you guys all right well
that's both be narcissistic
that's nice to know so trisha on
machiavellianism you got a 2.67
and remember the high is three point oh
it sounds good
yeah 86. so again
you're relatively low in
machiavellianism nice
narcissism you got 3.55
oh remember that a higher score is 3.86
so
yeah that's consistent with your npi
narcissism score
a little bit high but nothing out of
control high average probably because
i'm below the high no you're almost
high right but i'm not high at that
level and then
you're a 3.0 and ah you know kind of a
high number is 3.4
she's fine yeah so like
if i could say she's not a saint like me
but she's like
a plebian i'm not a psychopath i'm not
[ __ ] my intern
no no not a psychopath but but even that
score kind of surprised me because
because i think you're hyper emotional
right yeah
yeah i i didn't understand that score
it didn't didn't fit for me for you
right i yeah i feel like i am
that oh because that means you have no
emotion psychopaths have no emotion
right so the high
that is weird you're sort of
hyper-emotional i wonder if that's a
i don't know can we hear some of the
questions she tracked on or that she
she rated low on let's let's let's
re-eva let's revisit
yeah honest let's rev let's leave it be
honest
but i don't know if i should say this so
of course now say it
you got tired of the test no i i took
i don't know if i can mix the two i had
a xanax and then i took a percocet
is that effect out cause well
if you're taking a test about the the
intensity of your emotions
and you're and you're all [ __ ] up on
xanax yeah anxiety about the test and i
couldn't download it but then i had back
pain so i took the percocet oh my god
i did not drink alcohol on it
what does that mean two very important
things
so that's good because that explains
perhaps why the psychopathy test
didn't make sense to me and and the
drugs absolutely will adulterate the
test absolutely
yeah because you're feeling way more
circulated it was on the second test
because it was too many like strong
disagree and i was getting them all
confused i was like this is too many
boxes
yep i think that i think that explains
why that one was uh like
but but number two do not ever take
opiates and benzodiazepines together
that's how people die those are terrible
together terrible terrible terrible
do you can take your percocet or you can
take your xanax but do not pick both
together
for all those celebrity deaths you've
seen always that combination
really i thought it was alcohol and like
painkillers or xanax
no they condensed but nothing like
opiate and benzo look at oh wow
okay how far apart can you take them
four hours
be it i think it was like an hour apart
for real not good that's not good
doctors prescribe that [ __ ] all the time
like that and it drives me crazy
so i have a prescription for both give
it over
that prescription for what's your pain i
was in a car accident how long ago
a while ago but i have chronic back pain
from it that seems like a bad doctor to
prescribe percocet for so long right dr
drew it's not a great idea
well that's why i get the surgeries
plastic surgeries they'll prescribe you
percocets
that's why you guys that's not why i get
them but i i get them from the surgeries
holy [ __ ] like people do is they get
michael jackson
i'm convinced was getting plastic
surgeries to get the opiates really
i've seen that many times
it just sort of it's just sort of an
added bonus to the surgeries
oh my goodness but you would think
michael jackson of all people could get
anything he wanted he wouldn't
obviously he did it's hard to get him
illegally michael jackson was eventually
succumbed to some like extra
i forget what he what it was that killed
him but some extraordinarily strong
befall [ __ ]
i never heard of it administered outside
of a hospital when i heard
focal fall killed him it was a shocking
yeah
well like i said it was just for this
last part of the test because the first
part i did a different day and
this was the laws well as somebody who
has a perfect score in the dark triad
i'm worried and i want you to please not
mix it it was one time it was one time
well i've done it be honest it's not one
time
okay but one time that it counted where
it matters where i'm bringing it up let
me bring up something
that maybe you guys can address i know
that you romanticize
people who die young and their legacy
i do love that and i always this is not
good so i don't want to die oh my god
please don't 515 i don't want to die
no i know i know you're not suicidal but
you wrote no i know what happened to me
three times no but i know you
romanticized me
and you're also obsessed with your
legacy yeah i do think dying young you
become more famous and more
notorious people will miss me more when
i'm dead like she was an icon even
though now
don't you think this is a problem she's
taking percocet she's taking santa
she's obsessed one okay i don't i don't
think you
i don't think you're a drug addict but
i'm just saying i smell trouble
exactly it's the exact same thing as
being jealous
of monica lewinsky it's the exact same
thing yeah
because i'm jealous of somebody that
gets extraordinary fame
by sometimes horrible means and you know
and so um
what's the name from the doors you know
he's he's forever an icon because he
died at 28.
right jim norrison yeah that's all
that's a
it's a jealousy and and be careful you
know jealousy and
envy for narcissists people narcissistic
features
can really be a problem so you have to
envy is a very
problematic feeling be careful it was
more like when nicole was alive everyone
was like making fun of her and laughing
at her and then when she died it's like
oh she had such a
sad life and then there was like empathy
for her and i was like well
that's me like and meryl monroe she had
schizophrenia right before she died but
everyone tried to like make fun of her
and [ __ ] and then when she died like
well she was like a paranoid
so you think that you you the only way
you'll ever be understood is by dying
early
that's the only way i'll get anyone on
my side like everyone's through a lot of
people are
no now even people even people who
advocate so much for mental health is
like
oh like that's too far oh she needs to
get out of control when that's the whole
point is i can't get it under control
like it's so hard no but people do
support you you're wrong
that's so not sure why do you think i
made all those videos all the comments
on the last one which you knew
were all against me they were all just
like wow like how did ethan a letter do
that and like all that
that i mean i don't know how to convince
you but
you have a lot of supporters especially
since we've been doing this i don't want
to die do
me i do i'm not trying to kill myself no
you don't want to i love myself i'm a
narcissist
i know you don't want to die i'm just
saying the fact that you romanticized i
wouldn't mind i'll just say that way
like if it happens i don't mind when my
time is coming i'm a catholic i don't
believe in suicide i believe i need to
get to heaven like
i'm also jewish but catholic she's not
jewish i'm converting not that i care
but she's not okay well i'm on my way to
convert my boyfriend's an israeli jew
you don't have the you you wouldn't even
make it
100th away through jewish conversion
those [ __ ] they don't [ __ ] around
it's not like dunk you're jewish
like the the christians go dunk your ass
you're christian now
it's not like that anyways i don't
really mix on honestly i didn't know you
weren't supposed to be
completely clear even when i had them i
got my stomach pumped one time and they
never told me that they weren't like
they weren't like don't mix the two they
said just don't do it with alcohol so
like no one ever told me don't mix
a painkiller with them i'm sure they
didn't i'm sure they didn't that drives
me crazy that people give those both
those medicines together and don't give
you a warning
yeah the problem is if we do not want
you to die we do care about you we do
not yes
i don't want you i don't want to die and
by the way you you're
you are having i think a deeper impact
by getting your conditions treated and
then talking about
them dying yeah it just becomes this
weird sort of mythological thing
you're being very realistic and
forthcoming yes
what are relatively common conditions
you have in the you have cultivated all
the love and hate in the world right
you've done
that's been your thing for a long time
so it's going to take a while for that
to settle down yeah
hopefully what is it about so the so if
you take the
opioids and the benzos it slows your
heart rate that's the problem in your
heart is just like i'm sober
i'm done i can't beat anymore no it's
the
the opiates suppress your respiratory
center
oh you stopped breathing and when you
put the benzo on top of it it
really puts rocket fuel on that and you
just stop breathing
oh [ __ ] oh my gosh
i'm scared because like everyone noticed
like my neck and then i went to go get
my thing checked out on my neck and they
sent me to an ekg get an ekg oh yeah
because someone said
i have shortness of breath but i don't
have coverage oh my god what if i'm
dying what happens
well no you're not unless you're on a
bunch of drugs he's saying you have to
be super high and then you stop
like you block out
i don't know someone who specializes in
the neck and i have like this greater
thing and i got the blood work i got
like a scan
and then they sent me to a cardiologist
and i was like why i know i it was all
last week it was very
there was there was comments saying
trisha has something on her neck she
should get it checked out
if you can see i mean i don't see that i
actually don't see it even yeah i went
on friday
i don't know i don't know i couldn't see
it either now i'm scared about it i was
like what the hell why the [ __ ]
did you have one what was it your
thyroid
well i just went uh like literally
thursday to get all my tests i went to
like the quest lab place to get my blood
work and then i did my ekg so i haven't
gotten anything back this is all like
last week because they told me what two
weeks ago and then i was like i should
get it checked out i guess which makes
sense because i have like anyways this
is a whole other thing but
i can't lose weight and i've been like
eating healthy and like working out and
then my acne so i just it's i don't know
i don't know there may be something
wrong with me but what we've established
today that there is
just add it to the list well um
so you guys said just a sneak peek
trisha gets so mad when i do this watch
what so just like a snake see you're
trying to trigger me trisha gets so mad
watching no because i know that you will
because
when i'm not talking about you you get
upset no that is not true
watch just watch you're gonna get mad
when i talk about this teddy fresh
no okay but good call so
on our episode that we're filming
tomorrow as a teaser you guys said there
are some interesting results there
yes trisha is not uh alone
nor is he uh the leader of the pack
[ __ ] you hear that
holy [ __ ] i know who it is i know it is
but i can't say her name
her you can guess right i mean
you can guess you you think it's ila i
think it's she who must not be named
you can say her name i'm scared to say
it
didn't test any did we test any females
mark yeah
too yes but i think you guys are going
to be very very surprised tomorrow oh my
god
i am so excited so well we'll talk to
you guys if you can make it or not i
totally understand if you can
and if not we'll just we'll dan is the
only one that knows the real answer
so he he'll he'll officiate in your
guys's uh stead
wow i'll play doctor for the day but
doctor first of all dr drew he's
everywhere that's just everywhere he's
on youtube he's on periscope even in all
places i didn't know people are on
periscope facebook
facebook instagram he's on your mom's
house dr drew after dark dr drew live dr
drew dr drew dr drew
just google dr drew
dr young you teach at usc
i do in the in the marshall school of
business well oh you're wait your
business
your your business professor oh so what
are you doing here
well i i work in the entertainment
business
you know the human behavior part of
economics and accounting
oh how interesting well thank you so i
mean
thank you so much for taking time out of
your day to do this it really means a
lot that that you would come on and do
this for us
it was fascinating so final thoughts on
what should we do anything to change it
or is it jerry springer
okay what is our final thoughts i've got
ideas mark you first
no i again i think that at least we hope
that
you know these tests have provided you
with you know some insight into
personality dimensions and perhaps a
better way for you guys to understand
each other as you understand the scores
that that we've talked about
um but just because you have these
numbers doesn't really mean anything
about having
a disorder per se we're just trying to
point out the different traits that you
you know have evinced um by taking these
instruments
i i completely agree with that that that
is virtually my
my thought we will take none of that to
heart but thank you
well that's my that's my next thought my
only concern is your guys relationship
well here's what i think is going to
happen i think i think
you are going to use my low scores
somehow to continually insult me
am i allowed to continue to insult you
yes no no it's fine it's not about
family it's fine then yes you're right
but you will you will continually use
the fact that i am a saint
below average and by the way the fact
that i score
so low on these tests is probably the
only reason that i could sit here and do
this show with you
i think that's more patience rather than
narcissism i think you could use a
little more
do you agree with that doc doctor it
would be that it's the reason you can
sit there and do the
show and make it entertaining you see if
i were
if i were there it would not be
entertaining i think it would be dr drew
okay you guys want you guys want to get
in touch and do a show by all means i
think
trisha if you and i were to do it we'd
have to be ant we'd have to be focused
on somebody else we'd have to be taking
phone calls that kind of thing
and that would be different and
entertaining are you pitching a show to
my fellows we're
good together that show wouldn't last
that show oh my it's dr drew he did a
little bit
like what are you talking about let's do
it again
first of all who are you to give people
advice on anything that's the whole
point is i'm not your typical like
doctor or you i'm like a little
where the conflict would come again
right all right okay okay god bless
you guys have my blessings this is the
last time
the two of us talking would not be
interesting because i'd be
you know what you are dr drew you're the
best friend that comes in and [ __ ] the
wife
and ruins the [ __ ] marriage that's
you right now i would love to
i mean i think most wives would love
that if dr drew was that person
yeah okay well if you're gonna cheat it
would be with dr jerome
for sure let's not forget about that um
dr dre you do look very buff in your
jacket by the way you're married right
dr drew
married 30 years and now how the uh that
that this is uh something uh up front
uh ethan is going to be too threatened
to have me ever back on the show
that's not true see that's not true
this the fact that unless he can watch
then he's by the way
the fact that i got this low score such
[ __ ] because i
feel like i am a confident person i will
gladly have you back
i don't care if you install anything
look see you can have a defensive over
that you get on
no because i know you're gonna [ __ ] i
know that you're no
i know that you're gonna keep using this
even though you're the psycho
i'm the same and you always use that why
can't i have one thing to like to dig
at you for a g because i'm a perfect
human being and you shouldn't be able to
say anything about insecure you can use
any of this against me i'm not no i'm
kidding i'm not insecure either
okay so that part that's the part i'm
concerned with which which is
uh i love you both but but because it's
entertaining it's kind of unstable
this relationship and there will be
blow-ups in the future there will
be yeah and what should i do that's
another question so if i see her eyes
like turning red and she's like going
which i saw there and i don't know what
to do so what do i just walk away i mean
what do i do
you can just be like
maybe in the middle of a show and you're
trying you have dual
you know sort of yeah we're on camera
you're trying to
make a show and you want to not trigger
her so much
but you have to get used to
de-escalating things and that i don't
know how to
de-escalate when she goes into pushing
so the nanny thing it was a jab why
don't you just be like
next topic inside oh okay tell me why
i'm a bad parent tell me why my mom
should be watching my kids like you just
kept going for it
i did it as an off jab you could have
just been like all right let's get you
know what i mean like
it wasn't a job but yeah that's what
makes the show interesting yeah but i
can't let that go
you have to learn where that line is you
have to really learn it and just stop
you
just go okay but i i felt like at that
point there was no saving it i could
tell
it was all no it wasn't until the most
came in and everyone was making jokes
and all of a sudden i'm like wait was
that all a joke was that all just like
when it was like a very serious thing to
me then i was just like that's when i
like started like snapping i was like oh
my god was just trying to look like i
was just trying to make light of it
because
moses walks in with he goes away to get
pizza we have a total meltdown
he comes back with we were all happy
when he left and when he comes back
ever it's like we're it's like nuclear
right
and so i was trying to make light of the
fact that moses came with the pizzas and
i was like hey
moses the pizzas are here and uh
apparently
it doesn't feel like i was i'm looking
to make it look stupid on the show like
i'm just supposed to be embarrassed like
bring up the ela thing not on camera but
that's what started it all and i was
like wow you're just trying to make me
look stupid and look bad in front of
people like for no reason
and i would urge you trisha when you
start feeling that way bring
that up because i don't think he knew
you were experiencing that yeah
you start to experience shame
humiliation all that stuff that you're
trying to talk about
you have to say i'm being triggered
these are feelings
yeah i would respect that but also to
say like when i
said that thing about let's not talk
about ela i was going to cut that
so i'm sorry if i made if i embarrassed
you in that moment but my intention
wasn't to broadcast that to everybody
either when i said the good news is what
now when you say look i apologize i i
really believe that as compared to where
you guys were at the beginning of the
show so whatever we've done
whatever we've done you guys are sort of
in a better certainly a better more
connected place right now
yeah we by the way we did talk a lot we
talked a bit before we came on and kind
of buried that
and i talked to ela already too like i
think that was like the big thing for me
because i was more embarrassed about
what i said about ela
you it's like whatever yeah and it's
fine i'm just kidding
i really don't take offense to anything
you could say i know you don't yeah
yes what i'm saying is i there will be
future fights so i guess i will be back
yay
yeah maybe we just subconsciously were
like maybe it's time to just
go wild because we know he's coming next
week
[Music]
hey guys one last thing to think about
and that is if you think about a lot of
celebrity marriages
where you have you know two celebrities
together often they don't survive and
the reason is
because if you have two high-level
narcissists in a
it just explodes so maybe what we've
discovered here is that
if one person is high narcissism and the
other is not
that's why the show works yeah that's
what i'm saying
okay yeah that's true thank you for the
observation doctor
and basically um
i think and i think i think
my opinion really is that i'm always
willing to make it work and there's
nothing you can say or do
or you could say and storm out or
whatever it is that that's going to make
me
abandon you okay
but but you know but trisha believes you
will yeah
you will do so you don't believe me
because he even wanted to take a break
he didn't want me to be on for this show
like originally he said
i wasn't going to do the show without
you but you wanted to take a break you
wanted me to take a break when i didn't
want to and i was like oh so that's like
pushing me that's how it's happening
i keep trying to explain to you but you
know it's the problem is between ela
and moses okay they have a family issue
but you kept saying i don't think you
can continue the show i don't think the
show is like worth it anymore that's
what you said on history live
oh well so the problem is
that tricia really has issues with
abandonment and when you go down that
path
it's very evocative for her i will not
abandon you
and what will happen is she will abandon
you
before you have a chance to abandon her
and that's what i try to do i try to be
like you know what
you can't fire me i quit so i was like
you know what i'm going to quit because
he kept saying on h3 live this show's
not worth it it's not worth the family
drama and i was like well in that case
then i don't care about you either and i
will quit the show
all right that's not good and by the way
i don't take that seriously because i
know what i feel like i know
who and how and what you feel in your
heart and so when you go to those places
i don't take it personally
but the problem again she means she
means when she when it's real to her
it's real
it is real that's what i'm saying but i
know she comes around i know she i know
you come around
gotta be really careful with that
because it can be a problem
well okay i listen the issue is
it's external it's not between me and
you necessarily
it's about what happens it's about what
sometimes you say we've talked about
boundaries before
it's about what you say about elis
family and the substance we never had
this conversation off camera it was
always on camera where i just assumed it
was like for the show you don't mind me
poking at it it's like reality show
where you just say stuff to poke people
and you never told me off camera like
hey really it's not talking about it
but i was wrong natural boundaries on
our show like you literally like to say
so much to say mo to say that somebody's
brother hates them and their mom's not
invited to the wedding oh my god
and it was so clearly a joke where i'm
like dan and it was not a joke when i
said you guys were invited
i mean just be honest everybody
perceived that as not being a joke
go ahead dan no i mean
trish is right you guys talk [ __ ] all
the time i i don't know i don't think
you should have been as offended as you
were
at least without having the conversation
off the air the conversation off the air
i agree
but i wasn't offended i just said we
can't talk about this
i said ila doesn't want to talk about
the family talking about two different
things now though
yeah you just want to wait i'm not
offended i'm not offended by anything
you ever
told you're not invited to the wedding i
joked him and eli is like you know what
dan and his girlfriend are invited but
you're not invited you really think i'm
gonna invite dan and his girlfriend over
here no no that was a joke that was
the same sentence yeah there was a
different comment where you said it was
in that same circumstances like and not
his mom either
clearly and if it's not a joke it's not
a joke you missed it whatever but it's
like
that said one time you guys cut it out
and you never addressed why you cut it
out you never said hey don't do that
that's not cool never you just cut it
out and then i was like oh okay they
just cut it out like not a big deal they
just didn't like it or whatever
but you never once said this is a
serious problem ela's like family's
intention of her no one told me anything
moses didn't tell me you didn't
how was i supposed to know it was an
offhanded journey because eli kept
talking to him about how he either
should talk to me that was a whole point
how am i supposed to know something i'm
saying is that offensive to people i
thought took it as light-hearted like
who cares we talked about it
it wasn't one incident and dan you have
to back me up here but don't
unless you agree with me is that
continually
throughout episodes you're always making
comments about moses
not being close to his relate to his
family
so i kept doing it and you never once
told me off camera that it's not that
you don't like that stop doing it you
said i always sat on camera you were
just like it's the way you poke me
about everything in my life you do it
too to me that seemed like a
an obvious boundary and on the show i
would be like you have to stop saying
that
but you're right i should i agree with
you i'm getting confused where the
boundaries are you guys need to talk
about that
that's it for me that's the only
boundary and and
speaking of boundaries weren't we
heading towards the exit about five
minutes ago yeah
yeah you guys have buddy what do you
guys got something to do
sorry what a couple of doctors you got
nothing better to do
i'm sorry okay thank you dr drew
dr young thank you so much for your time
we love
and appreciate you guys so much and wish
you all the best so thank you so much
[Music]
okay well uh
i love those guys i love them too i love
dr drew like in a weird really nice
way and he's i think he's he's handsome
so that makes you want yeah
it's a little uncomfortable because i
because i have the condition right
once the [ __ ] me i'm like oh [ __ ] we
like you
together you're trying to already you
know dr doesn't want to [ __ ] you
but you have that three out of three on
vanity right so
you never know you never know okay
that's true but like
you have to temper you with your
feelings about whenever you think oh
that dude definitely wants to [ __ ] me
just remember i do have a three out of
three on vanity
which means they do want to [ __ ] me or
what no it means that your
filter is is [ __ ] up i guess
i just never been turned down by like
someone i wanted to have sex with so i
just always assume
everyone has sex with me but yeah you're
probably right i'm not gonna lie
you've never been turned down well what
does it look like when you try to [ __ ]
someone cuz like
i never initiate it i always have the
personality so so that seems like a
confirmation bias
wait what do you mean if they're trying
to [ __ ] you they're interested in in you
yeah but like every guy i've been with
obviously
obviously not you or people that are
married or really shipped i'm saying in
general
like i had okay i want to say here's
here i'll i'll place this stuff i'll
place this gauntlet down
okay if you [ __ ] dr drew then i will
agree with you i'll be like you know
what relationship you are the sex
goddess i bow down to you yeah well most
what is motive scary he's out you know
what i mean it's all part of it's for
the uh
it's for the love of the game it's not
about him
oh my god um yeah
that was really good mm-hmm how did you
feel about the results
um it was good i guess like yeah it was
good no surprises
no i also don't think like narcissism is
like that bad of a thing you know like i
i think people can be
people that are on like narcissists like
sociopath they throw those words around
so much manipulative i hate when people
just like throw things around like
they're freaking like
like like they're doctors that know
everything i'm like okay let's like calm
down
people sociopaths in a really you know
extreme
high spectrum it is very it can be very
damaging
but it seems like it seems like
obviously you
you scored pretty high on some stuff but
like not
crazy i think the vanity and the
exhibitionism
was the two parts where you were like
scored really which they said is like
not hurting anybody ever also like doing
that yeah you're not you're not
necessarily exploiting other people
because you
because you think you're hot although it
did get you an unfollow it got me an
unfollow from you
when i sent you my game yeah like on
fire i did unfold they did cost you that
one you did
i was like i would follow you back
immediately if you stop posting it's all
porn on my twitter so that's so you know
i understand i follow you on instagram
and i always like your posts you do
i've only seen it a few times but thank
you i appreciate it well whenever
they're on my feed
i don't know how instagram does that
[ __ ] yeah you don't post that much but i
do like yours when you post too
thank you so much should we um i have to
say i'm kind of surprised by how low i
i didn't think that i was gonna hit very
high
but i'm kind of surprised by it i
guessed it i said eight and it was a
seven i knew
because i just like you're not a
narcissist i mean there's a lot of
things to say about you like you're a
hypocrite and stuff but like i don't
know oh my god
[ __ ] i think that's your only flaw can i
say this i mean this is a compliment
like i
there's really not wait wait wait wait
what am i hypocritical
i think you are somewhat hypocritical of
like things like the contradictions
where you say oh it's not the same thing
when it is like you guys can like the
not to go back and forth but you just
you really don't think you're i don't
think hypocrisy was even on that scale
i'm not saying it wasn't so let's get
the doctor i also don't think you like
admit you're wrong that's your only
fault it's like you really don't think
you're wrong most of the time
like you're like what did we do wrong
like you can't even admit that you're
like five percent
wrong in that situation i have tol i
fully admitted i was wrong i should have
talked to you yeah i think now you come
around to it but it takes you a minute i
thought
yeah but i mean i agree i fully should
have told you about that boundary before
we went
on 100 and um
there was something else that i i mean
it's crystal clear now obviously that
boundary like obviously i'm like oh [ __ ]
like it was such a [ __ ] storm but
i think overall like i get it i
you know
i'm excited for tomorrow's episode y'all
better not miss that
i definitely want to why you don't care
i just can't i try so hard because
you're my friend and i try so hard to
like watch it
yeah i think the i know you love them
but i just think the
overall everyone else is so boring i
just
can't and like i get it you they're pop
you guys are popping in popular so i'm
not
that's like me saying i don't like david
dobrik when everyone loves them and
everyone loves you guys so it's not a
job or anything
well anyway i'm just i'm just really
curious about who's off the charts
are we am i being fired like because if
not dr drew has offered me a spot
you go do your show with dr drew you
know what i mean maybe i mean
god bless you guys but so but you guys
have time to figure that out because we
this is officially
our last episode of frenemies
not forever we're taking a two-week
break
at the end of the year we always take a
two-week break because we like to let
the guys take
time off because we all work really hard
i took it personally when you said to
take a break and you're like we're gonna
take a break and it's like oh [ __ ] oh no
it wasn't you
everybody do this every year thank god
that means we take a week we take a
break
at the end of every year to give these
guys who work so hard
time off so that they can relax a little
bit
so this is our last week and we'll be
back in
january when is our first uh backup dan
if you have a calendar in front of you
well it'd be the monday or you know
whatever you guys will see it it'll
pop up probably the week of the 11th or
the 12th
oh really well we usually post on
tuesday so i mean potentially the 12th
of january oh my god that's so far away
wait yeah what about the first week of
january
what about it that's the one that one of
the weeks that we're taking off i said
two
the last two weeks of december dan's
trying to get himself another week off
oh okay
well then the then the fourth through
the fifth the fourth or the fifth of
january that sounds better it does sound
dance like i will be back the 15th of uh
february oh [ __ ] i'm gonna be
sad i'm gonna be sad and i think it can
we also say that i talk to igola
and like can i say that or no you just
yes you can talk about it okay i think
we did talk yesterday on the phone
and we talked but we did talk yesterday
and
like i will say like one of the cool
well people might not agree with it but
i thought it was like the coolest thing
when i like obviously think i was most
embarrassed about was calling like elo
the
words that i said yeah it was it was
gross and cringy and whatever and when i
apologize ela she goes oh that doesn't
bother me and i was like okay like it
should but it made me feel
better like you know what i mean she
like understood where i was coming from
not that it's right i'm not excusing me
but it did feel like i thought oh that's
pretty [ __ ] cool like that she's kind
of like it's fine like i get it
that's what i'm trying you can cause
most people wouldn't be this that stuff
doesn't bother me
us at all you can say anything you want
that's what i'm trying to say is the
boundaries is
i won't i don't want to say anything i
know but i'm saying like that to me
that's like i
we get over that that's fine it's the
it's the family stuff that's all
most people can't i feel like if someone
were to call me that like that's why my
ex-wife broke up with me i called his
ex-wife
that really yeah and he literally was
like because he's a cuck like he
actually is one he probably scored zero
on that scale like he was like anything
she's like
oh i was doing patreon at the time and
he's just oh anyway i should go into
this whole detail but she would throw
and take the kids away she was crazy and
he's just like a little cluck
i'm not good either i'm not touching
that i don't [ __ ] know
anyway that's a dirty word it's a nasty
word i don't like calling people that
like i don't think about
[ __ ] and i i want to reiterate i never
once ever said she was rude or
disrespectful just to reiterate for
everyone i actually never said that
about her ever like
here comes the compilations no please
please i challenged someone to find me
saying that she was rude or unwelcoming
when i always said the opposite maybe i
said we're awkward
like whatever moses doesn't like you but
water
i am awkward in general by the way i'm
wearing teddy fresh is this an elo
design or is this a ethan design or is
this a team design what is this well we
have a huge
team that works on graphics and i mean
it's like everything we do as a teammate
this is really cute it's got teddy bears
with little christmas lights
i mean you yelled at me and said don't
wear teddy fresh anymore so i wore a
supreme shirt today
and you showed up in a teddy freddie
well i was trying to do my piece
offering i was like look i'm gonna wear
a teddy fresh i got my h3 mugs these
will be available soon vintage mugs
i'll sell them come to me you only have
two actually a four now because you gave
me two when i was on the show so now i
have a collection which i
really you're gonna open a shop trish is
gonna be able to open her own merch shop
honestly where the [ __ ] you get that
chocolate milk just pull the chocolate
milk out
after a two-hour podcast i feel like my
sugar is a little low because i feel
like i'm about to pass out so i'm just
going to should that be refrigerated can
chocolate milk go two hours out of the
fridge is it still cold
i mean i just got a 7 11 on my way here
i'm sure it's fine
yeah it's probably fine it gets sick
it's a surprise you pulled it out of
nowhere i was like chocolate milk
i don't know should we get another pizza
i wish we could get another peace
offering pizza because i'd eat that with
you right you want to eat a pizza
but we'd have a lot of ways we should
have thought about it before
oh i was i ate the [ __ ] way you ate
it
why was i gonna throw it out i couldn't
even eat after i was so sick to my
stomach and then like i just was so sad
about it because it was my idea
and then moses paid for i'm like moses
why didn't you grab the pizzas on the
way out
i was so annoyed that he left them i
thought that's why he was down here
getting the pizzas
oh dude that would have been so douchey
he's like [ __ ] you guys
i'm taking the pizza actually all all of
us were standing around having a really
sad pizza party
and then i heard dan say it wasn't even
go which is [ __ ] because pizza is
the best pizza
again i can see when i'm wrong they gave
the thick crust and i think it
it made it way too heavy and we all got
sick exactly
you should have had just the regular
yeah i can see it once again
the tree box everyone thinks it got
sponsored by that the pizza hut tree box
was like everywhere
everyone ordered it anyways we're all
good i don't want to separate moses from
his family i apologize like
i want him to be with his family and we
all i want you all to come to the
wedding i want like okay
and we and we and we all wish the best
for you guys i mean genuinely you know
so anyway we'll be back oh and by the
way trisha got me the best present ever
she got me a playstation five which
i should have i know well i didn't i
didn't know if we were going to have
that well
somebody has to pick it up maybe i can't
come drop it off i won't stay
i'm not that person oh i just didn't
want to put you out of your way
yeah come here i would like to give you
it should we get a pizza and eat it
together okay and then pass off the ps4
we can film it well i thought you might
have already had it why don't we do
why don't we do like we can make like a
tick tock or something of like the
christmas miracle the ps5 pizza party
and no the real miracles i got it at uh
retail value i did not pay extra for so
when she told me she said i i got you a
christmas present it's a ps5 the first
thing i asked is
did you buy it on stockx because i
do not support those [ __ ]
who sell that [ __ ] markup and i've
refused to buy from them
and the perfect aspect is that she got
it at retail from someone at best buy
yeah which was like just for a shout out
and the price but
hey i'll take it i love the [ __ ] hey i
mean shout out's worth way more than
what
well the reason i told you is because
you were looking at your phone talking
about like trying to get and i was like
[ __ ] i feel like he's gonna like get
someone and because i already got it and
i have no use where i was like wait i
should just tell him so no one like
tries to scramble to get it on stockx or
something because well we
all these guys everybody's been trying
to get ps5s none of us have got
one i had the ps5 hookup i mean yeah
literally like
a b ian zach then i don't think you care
and then and then ab even has his own
team in the discord he says
none of us can get it who i'm just i
don't i don't understand who the [ __ ] is
able to buy these
people who know general managers of best
buy well they're just bots though
it's just it's so [ __ ] up i my dream
is that all these bots buying the ps5s
that that sony gets their [ __ ] together
and floods the market and they all just
have to like sell it under retail
because nobody wants but now you have
one i didn't get you any games or
anything i don't know what i don't like
i'll just i'm gonna download them okay
because i don't know
yeah i don't need games yeah that's
honestly such a thoughtful gift thank
you so much well i was so excited
because we talked about during goat yoga
and i was like that's the gift that's
what i'm going to get them and then i
was so excited about it and then i was
like i've been thinking a lot about what
to get you
and no i i don't i really don't want
anything when i say i don't want
anything i like really mean it cause i
really do by myself
you also told me when i get someone a
gift and don't reciprocate i get angry
i don't get angry you get disappointed
maybe
but but i really don't expect it because
i do get myself everything like i'm
seeing shane tonight and he does the
best gift so i'm like i need to get
something great for him you know what i
mean
we'll see him tonight i don't know like
last year he got me cartier bracelet
like the year before like he gets me
he's like all out
not saying you i'm just saying he's like
the he's the ultimate we brought the
same with gift giving
so then i was like and he's hard to buy
for cause he's a guy you know what i
mean so it's hard but
i'm trying to think yeah because like i
know you like jewelry and all this bling
and stuff but i'm not no you don't you
don't have to get me anything but i was
trying to think of something really
thoughtful like this menorah
like how do you have someone that just
blings like like put me in touch with
your bling person
i got you something from them too i
should have brought that i have that
right i wish i had a blank person
because i have good ideas for that
i got you another thing bling but i
didn't want to be overwhelmingly weird
and being like here's gifts because i
love gifts i love giving gifts you tell
me what you've got me blinked
um i feel like i could wait until the
new year i feel like because it actually
kind of has to do with our set a little
bit too
can you put me and tell you the willing
person so i can bring you out something
i have all the bling things i need i
have so many bling i have a bling birkin
i
blink everything you really you know
what honestly can i say and i'm not just
saying this like these cops are honestly
like the most awful thing like the fact
that whoever remembered that i
wanted these and gave them to me and it
was me oh well then that's to me means
like a lot and i really mean that like
that's cool like
for instance like okay i really wanted a
pig backpack from shane and sold out or
whatever but he gave me like a white one
that wasn't even for sale yet for my
birthday he gave me other things but
that's me was the most thoughtful gift
because i was like oh [ __ ] also
we set aside i don't i don't know if you
got it yet but you asked for some teddy
fresh that's all sold out that we sent
you
i don't know if it's right there i got
it the day i got i went home and stormed
off and then there was like a teddy
fresh box i'm like do i unbox this like
is it open um i i did open it but i was
going to do it on camera but it felt
like it authentic it felt like it's not
real to do it
so that was nice yeah no i appreciate it
i remember i made a special note i said
trisha this this no you do you are good
that's what i'm saying that stuff means
more no but i need to surprise you with
something
this was a surprise i saw these and i
did get really excited i was like oh my
god that's really nice you do have a
weird
if you do love those mugs i love these
mugs and i stole them when i didn't
steal them you gave them to me each time
i did the podcast i thought how cool and
you know your makeup
i have four so if you ever want to use
them come to my house i'll have a set
for everybody and i do try to hang out
with you guys you guys said that you
never try to like hang out
socially with you guys and we did try to
plan one one time you said after theater
goes bad at six o'clock
but then it was the weekend of the
election and i got chaos and covet and
all that stuff like that but i do try
and hang out with you i think it's the
covet thing i know but i want to
socialize i like to i want you guys a
part of i want to be a part of the
family i want you guys a part of like i
want everyone to be together
so i try it i know it's kova but just to
make that clear
i want to be in but it's oh yeah i think
it was once
and you made it sound like you're asking
us every week no no and then about
we won't talk about it but you said
something like that could be fun we
could do that this weekend and then i
never heard from you i'm like hey i
thought we're supposed to hang out this
weekend you're like oh we got busy and i
was like okay this was like the first
episode
of the show and the point is i want to
be a part of your guys's life and vice
versa i thought
like truly like when i first started
dating like moses said that would be
like a good idea because i was like oh
then i can get close to you guys like i
really wanted to and not in like a user
way but i was like oh that's so cool
because like i
was like i liked you guys i was like
this is a good like in obviously
is that i don't know what monkey
millionaires but either way i really
like you guys and i wanted to be part of
this it's why i like from the beginning
i wanted to come to like your house and
be a part of your lives and
everything the successes of this channel
jokingly mock but you say you say you
always say how uncomfortable you are
here and that you hey
i'm very awkward yeah i'm super i need
to get over that though i'm just not
well anyway we won't be here soon i
understand this is my this is my home
turf right so either way it's your home
server because it's your channel your
employees yeah and the studios are much
more neutral think about if we were like
on the real housewives of
bro on bravo right and like we had this
fight like bravo employees aren't gonna
give a [ __ ] that we had this they will
like egg it on more
personal attacks but because it's you
and your family do you know what i mean
well even your family and stuff
everything but if it was on a tv show
where no one had anything invested
they'd be like yeah trish get um like
get the personal stuff going yeah that's
true so it is i get it i'm learning i i
i but but
but for the most part they just sit here
silently unless i ask
but but you're right these are my guys
right and they would
never they would never go against them
that's not true dan
i i dan's gone if dan kind of [ __ ] me
over sometimes i'll tell you
dad throws me under the bus no i was
shook because i think me and dan always
had a rough start he didn't want me on
the show from the very beginning yeah on
friday he threw my ass under the bus no
i no
he wasn't throwing yourself and
everyone's like yeah he was bringing
awareness like
oh i think because not to throw a b out
of the bus but he summarized the video
wrong saying that i was
yeah abby kind of screwed me i have to i
think abe screwed me
because he's like she's mad at the chest
on ebola side i'm like what chat what
are you talking about i was just like
watching something on my phone
no but also abe summarized your video
poorly it was not one thing he made it
sound like it was like
trashing us though i was like praising
like i was like i want to be upset i
think
av screwed me on that one but he did say
in his wrist
after i was already charged up and angry
at you and ready to talk about it on on
live
he goes maybe it's not as bad as i made
it sound so why wouldn't you watch it
as dan says why is it 40 minutes talking
about it
well i did well to be fair i didn't talk
that much i didn't really like 40
minutes yeah
i didn't have time i didn't have 40
minutes in the morning we were working
no you guys talked 40 minutes
about the comment you pinned which was
[ __ ] up oh my god you didn't see the
video the whole video was me just being
like a comment
the comment had nothing to do with the
video and then also dan mentioning
bringing up the the point which you now
agree with him is like oh maybe you
should have mentioned
that camera dan is right and then you at
the time like what what but
it was it was it was like a it was nice
what dan
yeah i just jokingly said thank you yeah
no i was because you know i was you know
they're obviously going to be like
you're excited he's right no dan's right
and that's what i like how i like when
i don't expect them always to agree with
me and i like when they when they put me
in my place so to speak
it's just uh i'm putting in your place
it's just like nobody's telling you a
difference
i get charged up they give me not
putting me in my place i was trying i
was
trying to lead into a joke but i hit the
brakes on it but i i appreciate when
they gave me that different perspective
and he was right okay and so but i
mostly i blame a b
true i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
yeah but you could say something
yeah give me a mic all right maybe wants
to say something
av the simp the ethernet thank you he's
har by the way a b before you talk ab
recently won
heartthrob of the crew do you agree with
that on what and what just like most
attractive crew member
um definitely okay there you go for sure
that's well you're going against like
yeah
it's a it's not a yeah what would you
give a mono at a one out of ten though
a b or d a b out of ten uh
i don't really i never liked young guys
in general even when i was young so i
would say like a
a five out of ten oh my god the bar is
low for friday
dude we are we are a bunch of wow that's
awesome
yeah but that's only because like i
don't know yeah yeah but heartthrob at
five is brutal
i mean that's awesome okay let's hear
what abe has to say number five
okay so when i summarized the video i
was going word for word
for sentences but i did say at the end
and dan could back me up it sounds worse
in text
i recommend that you watch it yourself
what do you mean you were really i
recommend you
by the way a b our show starts at 12
live and he sends me this summary at
like 12 50 and goes i recommend you
watch it it's like dude what am i going
to do
i just want to say i'm always the one
that has trisha's back that's all i'm
saying
oh it's not true no i swear no i mean on
friday
maybe i didn't express myself i meant
that the comments were really rough on
you that's what i was trying to say not
that you made that video because the
comments
i meant that like during not the initial
yeah
during the live i made the video cause
of the comments not because of you guys
there was i had nothing bad to say about
it i didn't read the comments i didn't
know what people were saying
h3 on the h3 during the live no no on
the on the front of me i'm sorry in
front of me i was yeah those comments so
that was my yeah those comments were for
the most part so i was just trying to
claim her name with the comments i had
nothing and i kept saying like how
amazing i think you are and ela's
talented and like how i want to be a
part of this and like all this
so done when you guys came for that i
was like wait what's up so so
did you watch it after all that no i
still haven't watched it it's too long
it's too long i mean i know but your
videos kind of they need to be edited
down a little bit
i people and then you made another one
that was like an hour 20 i was like
uh uh-uh girl i ain't got time for this
[ __ ] i've got it i got
you know what i mean yeah i felt bad it
was birthday but in all fairness you
made your first attack video on my
birthday
it's fine and that's when i had the meth
overdose and went to the hospital
okay whoa
[Laughter]
if you want to go there jesus um anyways
sorry you lost at the streamies too
oh my god that oh that was so weird the
guy who won so weirdo
i've never never heard of him by the way
no views it's so weird we're gonna talk
about it on uh on
uh on our next podcast of the week
promoting the next podcast no well
because but like this guy
he has like 20 000 subscribers on
youtube he averages 10 000 views per
pocket
i'm not saying that it's not a good
podcast because it doesn't have good
views but i never [ __ ] heard of the
guy
it's so weird because i i was going to
the stream because he's sucking
i know well i was looking for pictures
of who won best podcast i was expecting
either logan david or you guys for sure
and then i skipped past it because i
even see i'm like wait where's the
podcast and i was like oh
who is this person i was so confused
well i was like oh maybe he's
because there's there's lots of content
on youtube huge creators i was like
that i've never heard of and always
surprised me so i look up his channel i
was like the [ __ ] is this guy
it's it's weird i don't know but
whatever but that's what i think the
stream is
all these internet awards is a bunch of
[ __ ] like i mean seriously
i would go in front of me is nominated
actually i wouldn't i haven't
they just they they emailed me and they
said uh
be ready because if you win send us a
video accepting
oh so you thought maybe you would win i
was like okay cool maybe we'll win that
that would actually be fun you know
right for sure
and then and it was like some dude you
never heard of who gets 10 000 views and
again that doesn't mean it's not good
it's just odd what a weird setup though
to be like oh get ready to send us a
video if you weren't going to win
because they usually tell the winners
not to bring up trucks films but he knew
he was going to win a shorty award and
he just flew to new york because they
told him in advance he was going to win
well shorty's the [ __ ] [ __ ] them all but
here's the thing
like i'm not saying that guys doesn't
make a good podcast i've never seen it
right
but there's like a billion podcasts that
get 10 000 views
per episode right like why was he
nominated there's something fishy yeah
it's set up for sure like last year of
the year stop the steal
stop the steal wait is that his name no
his name is j
shitty what's what that's his name no
but seriously what
what is this guy's story like i'm
like who is he like what is his story i
don't know like even logan paul who
obviously
you know that's what i thought was gonna
win like obviously i've been in and out
with logan paul in terms of things but
like
i would understand if you won like the
guy's been through a lot he makes a good
product he has a podcast he puts a lot
of work into it
yeah it's big it's popular and so like
that would make
it's part of like a redemption arc i was
like oh i think and if logan paul won i
wouldn't even complain it makes
perfect sense yeah did he win last year
two
i don't think he did i think it was the
views or
mandates which yeah which by the way
isn't even on [ __ ] youtube yeah
they're so lazy on that podcast it's 40
minutes long and they have 20 other
people talking
about like i mean i mean what are what
are the metrics in it and i'm not
complaining but like
look at everything we do look at
everything we put in
some [ __ ] who nobody knows comes in
like what i just
i'd like some explanation i demand it
you [ __ ] it on the streamys like you
were sitting on there
yeah that's probably the sorties i'll
take a nomination i would have gone to
represent you i think we've been
nominated every year
really always surprising yeah i think so
yeah wow and you never won never never
that's okay but i never expected you you
have to play ball with these people too
do i
win yeah i [ __ ] them jay shitty
probably won because he immediately
emailed them back and was like yes i'll
fly out
i'll be there i have a video ready to go
well no no but
it was all over via the internet there
was no audience or anything
oh right right no they would and he they
even said because i tried to like play
ball a little bit because they're like
be on standby because if you win you
need to send us a video acceptance or
immediately and i said i'm standing by
you did
okay you were ready so i was like okay
i'll send you a video
because usually i just don't want to go
there because it's a schlep
so but this year i was like okay i'll
send you a [ __ ] video
my acceptance video was going to be
snarky though
i was already thinking about it i think
well i was gonna be like thanks for the
best podcast uh
but you know too bad joe rogan couldn't
be here who obviously
it wasn't even nominated it has like a
trillion more views than me
oh i want to be his co-host chill rogan
do you think he would let me on
or is it boys club over there wait you
mean it as an interview no i want to be
like a co-host
it's not enough to be an interview you
want to be on every episode of the joe
rogan podcast yeah
well if he has like if he's scoring like
saint
level low on the dark triad maybe do you
think he's a narcissist
do you think we'd but how do you think
he'd like me i don't know i don't think
about him actually though
he's definitely i what the [ __ ] do i
know about you i don't know but i think
all i know is all i know is that he you
peed do you smell it it smells so bad
that's so weird
i don't know i couldn't control it
that's weird do you really smell it no
wait did you really appear i'll be okay
i don't know just a little bit
why do you have to pee really bad no i
think something's wrong i don't know i
think something's wrong with you leaking
urine
he smelled it look he's like wait do you
leak urine
are you wearing depends or something no
it just
is it squirt huh is it squirt no i think
your dog knew i love it it's very odd
that you use leaking urine i want to
know more about it
he wanted to be picked up i don't know i
think my i think my um i don't know
has this happened before never i just
peed a little time
what oh my god but i just find that's so
odd i need more information about it
it just came out i have no idea i maybe
should see a doctor i don't know it
honestly just happened you don't smell
the first time ever no i don't smell it
the dog came right to me when i did it
oh fred you're so sweet you like
you like trisha's yarn you like sitting
in it you said yes
yes anyway we've said enough
yeah so we're on good terms everyone's
on with me anyways i don't know i'm not
getting into any of these are we just
going past the thing that you just feed
your pants i don't know it smells
it smells bad it smells gross i'm
embarrassed right now so can we not talk
about it
but i have to understand this phenomenon
i've never done that
you just let you expect let me just let
you know that you feed her pants
a reason that i don't know i will wrap
it up i just find it fascinating okay
bye well i don't want my dog in your
urine it's not in
my urine it's obviously finding
something comforting about my body it's
so sweet
yeah he never comes to me to like let me
hold him he's so
sweet i love him so much fred you're the
best ever i'll take him can i take him
for a week
over my dead [ __ ] body i love my dogs
like
my dogs are my heart i love them do you
love them equally you said that once
right you love them equally as your
child i'm not trying to like bring up
anything but
like obviously it's a theodore in a
burning fire first but
i think i love my my i love my pets like
i love my children
yeah obviously there's dif that that
means different things it doesn't mean
like
theater was the priority but you love it
yeah if the house is on fire i'm gonna
grab
you know and i if i have to save one but
like i love my dogs i mean i do it my
dogs are everything to me
you know what i mean you would let
theodore burn you said i'd grab him
okay if you're grabbing theodore i'll
grab oh we're together okay
you're like i let theodore burn no all
right
we're we're back but we're not we're
gone for a couple weeks so we'll see you
guys
in the january something's the beginning
of january you want to promote the
podcast i was on that they came for you
jay porton are you oh i can't wait oh
later yeah
we have to come back and respond to that
it's the last episode of the year right
now we have to
because dave portney is that his name
yeah apparently you did their podcast
and he was making fun of me it was
awkward and he didn't i don't know if he
knew his tourette's but he was making
fun of your twitches and your hand just
it was super awkward i didn't know what
to say i did defend you at the end of it
because i was like what do i
say this is so uncomfortable because i
was defending on stevo's apparently oh
my god you owed me what
stevo just hates me too i don't get it
but yeah i appreciate that
by the way stevo i don't i don't
remember what he said so i'm not i'm not
trying i'm not attacking stevo i like
steevo
he really dave party's a [ __ ] and i'm
gonna [ __ ] him up i actually i'm not
gonna
i think oh he is oh well
maybe we shouldn't fight he after i said
i love like jewish man he's like i'm a
jew
i'm like oh he's trying to be someone
who wants hot young like 20 year old
[ __ ] you know what i mean
yeah that's what i don't want i don't
like guys like that um
no it's not the judgment on that but uh
i don't i think it's odd that he has a
podcast with a 18 year old dude like bro
can you [ __ ] hang out with like
not a bunch of young tick tuckers you
freak a lot of people do that so i mean
there's nothing legally wrong with this
legally of course i'm not saying he's
breaking the laws off some famous tick
talkers yeah
he has money though he's machiavellian
that [ __ ] he should do a
narcissist test huh
he'd be off the chart i can't well
anyway i can't wait to see why are we
promoting this asshole's podcast
but i can't wait to see apparently
apparently he made fun of my tourette's
and [ __ ] not and it's awesome
it was a weird attack there's a lot of
things to attack you for
i don't know if i would go for that as
my first well
because you literally well yeah i can't
control it like it's it's better to cost
you fat or something good
or like me that i'll put on me because i
can control i can control my weight so
okay calling me fat whatever but if you
really can't control
huh look at that [ __ ] idiot taking
out
that's what he said yeah love it i can't
wait
dave porton is going down boxing match
is he big or small i think he's a big
guy i don't know i
wasn't there is he really i think he's
big he's stretching as a little guy
he looked pretty big he's very mask
energy can you look up his height dan
dave portney because i'm thinking boxing
match
a boxing match yeah it says he's six too
yeah he's playing what
i'm not boxing and he's pretty fit he's
just that macho guy he looks like a
little guy
he has a little guy energy i don't think
so he definitely has that mask
jock he's like the logan paul 20 years
later dude i get little guy energy from
dave courtney
oh my god that's not sorry thank you for
having me on the podcast no one else
wants me on there
he let me speak my piece about the
demilios and addison ray i don't know if
he let me or just want to find out
he just gossips about like 16 year old
girls i mean that's like
i don't know unlike me i said what do we
do
well right yeah we do it but his co-host
is like a [ __ ]
15 year old tick tucker 18. yeah i lower
the age but whatever
that's a big prison he just turned 18.
what
what am i talking about okay all right
guys thanks for watching i guess we
we're okay now and um
stay tuned for the tickets we almost we
almost didn't make it through
this last fight so well i'm thank you
and honestly thank you i was embarrassed
by last episode i appreciate you guys
for giving me it takes a lot to deal
with someone like me and i appreciate
you guys for being here still
yeah i want to be a part of your family
and your life oh my god freddie and make
money
and i'll keep a dog no you're not okay
all right guys thanks for watching